안녕하십니까. 최밀턴 여러분. 행복한
투자 예정을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝
브리프 6월 18일 목요일입니다.
일부 시작하겠습니다.
유리프로가 방금 [웃음]
화장실에서 막 뛰어왔는데 저는 오사인
볼트인 줄 알았습니다.
전일 중국 시장 왕정부장님
알아보겠습니다
>> 네. 어 어제는 테크주 상승하면서 상
지수 플러스 0.44% 5라고요.
흥승 테크 지수는 플러스 0.22%
2% 5라고 정식 거대 없는 3.1조
외 수준 그냥 유지했습니다. 업종별
좀 보시면 어쨌든 IT 커뮤니케이션
소재 업정 컨셉고 반면 에너지
자유소비제 필 소비제 업정 약세가
표였습니다. 어제도 반도체 전비주들이
급등세가 지소되고 있고요. 어
랭기테크는 실중 5% 올라가고요.
부판 화천는 4증 7% 올라고 조미
반도체 10% 정도 올라고 장증
테크는 요정 8% 장승 테크는
9.8% 8%
번주 리서치하는 구사이고요.
10% 장한가 기록했습니다. CCR
가격 추가 인상 확정 등용으로 관영
주도 강세 보였습니다. 동산 청률
3.2% 오라고요. 선단 정는 10%
호전 중심 4.2% 킨보드는 3%
오라고요. MLCC 가격 추가 인상에
대한 기대함으로 MLCC 관련주
어세도 강세되었습니다.
화자는 3.5%으로 하고 보화 테크는
4.9% 9% 모두 역사는
신고했습니다.
이번기 실적 기대감 그리고 건트레시버
출화형 상승 조전도 이용으로 건시
조제도 상승했습니다. 중제 5천날
2.2% 올라고 신 역수는 1.6%
천부 건동신 1.4% 올라왔어요.
요리 선물 공급 보조에 따라서 가격
추가 인상 기대감으로 요리 선유
관련주 어제도 급등했습니다. 중국
거선은 10% 정도 상한가
기록했습니다. 어 홍화 테크는
2.9% 9% 올라고 정재 테그
10% 모두 역사 역사 신고했습니다.
저가 매수 자금 유입으로 정력 기기
관련주도 반등했어요. 4번 테크는
7% 올라고 길서 주시는 3.4%
요시 동료는 4% 올라왔어요. 반면은
전기차 판매 지표 부신등에 따라서
전기차 권연수 어제는 좀 빠졌어요.
신념물 교체 금리 어제 염정 1bp
하라했습니다. 인념물 구체 금리는
영정이 피하라고 외양화 확률는 어제
소폭 전라되었습니다.
>> 감사합니다. 중국 시장도 한국 시장
아시아 시장 전반과 함께
>> 어 상승이었는데
>> 어 장 전체적으로는 한국 시장이나
일본 시장과 크게 다름이 없다라고
오늘은 그냥 믿고
>> 제가 어제 갑자기 생각난 질문이 오늘
아침에 왕부장님한테 물어봐야지라고
했던 게
>> 작년 2월인가요? 그 딥크 사태가
있었을 때네. 어 미국에서 이제
그러니깐 뭐 그와 연결된 것이 전부
다 100% 설명력이 있는 건
아니지만 엔비디아의 최신칩 중국 추출
기대도 있었고 어 이렇게 여러 가지
제재들이 있었는데 그 이후에 미국의
엔비디아 어 젠순항 CEO 등이
오히려 그게 더 중국의 기술력을
빠르게 발전시키는데에
도움을 주기 때문에 어 수출 규제
풀어 달라 이런 말도 있었고 했어요.
어 며칠 전에 그 앤트로픽의 가장
최신 버전 AI가 어 외국인 직원도
있으면 안 됐던가? 그 외부 다
>> 어 외부에 안 되고 뭐 수출 안 되고
뭐 이런 규제들이 있는데 아 또 이런
것들이 중국의 AI 발전에 오히려도
도움을 줄 수도 있지 않나 그런 생각
잠깐 해 봤는데 중국 시장 이제
분석하고 저희에게 이슈 종목 어
정리해 주시기 위해서 쭉 여러
자료들을 보실 텐데 그중에 혹시 그런
관련한 내용 혹시 보신게 있나
궁금했습니다. 이거는 뭐 이구는 항상
대회적으로는 뭔가 공급 중단 이런 거
얘기가 되게 많이 나왔잖아요.
>> 그냥 중국 반해적으로 가고 있어요.
그냥 대회적으로 공개로 다 개방
무료로 개방하겠다고 얘기했어요.
>> 아 중국은
>> 맞아요. 그래서 중국 요즘에 만든
그거 모델 있잖아요. 이거 이거
딥시크 저로 되는 모델 되게 많아요.
기업별 다 있으면 등센터도 있고
아래바도 있고 매도도 있어요.
>> 이거 다 무료로 대회 개방하겠다고
얘기했어요. 그래서이 미국 빼고 다른
지역 남미 종 뭐 종동 지역 유럽
아니면 그 동남마 다충 모델을 쓸 수
있게끔 만들었어요. 그래서
[목을 가다듬음] 이거를 써는
전학계도 다르게 나오고 있습니다.
>> 전략이 완전 다르게
>> 맞아요. 그래서 이거는 미국 재외하고
정세 MS나 화대할 가능성도 있다고
생각해요.
>> 음. 그럼 그렇게 되면 이제 오픈
소스라고 이제 보통 얘기하는데 그렇게
해서 아주 많은 사람들이 쓰게 만든
다음에 궁극적으로 유료하는 건가?
어떻게 되는 거예요?
>> [웃음]
>> 요화
왜냐면 요하고 있는데 다만 지금 토큰
가격은 너무 비쌌잖아요. 그래서
공급은 나중에다 더 공급 공급 더
추가하면은 토큰 가끔 내려가야 돼요.
>> 그래서 이거는 P 요구하는 아니고 Q
요구하는 겁니다.
>> 그래서 P는 계속 날려갈 수 있고
다만 Q가 올라가니까 훨씬는 이적으로
좋아질 수 있어요.
>> 음. 그렇구나. [목을 가다듬음]
이런 큰 틀에서는 어 3년 뒤, 5년
뒤 보면은 아 그러한 큰 방향성이
맞았다, 뚫렸다 아마 결정이 날 텐데
어 양국의 방향성이 완전히 다르다고
좀 말씀해 주셨으니까요.
>> 그 기준을 가지고 또 어떤 정책들의
변화가 있는지 한번 보도록
하겠습니다.
>> 네네.
>> 감사합니다. 밑에 오늘 이슈 종목은
>> 네.
>> 킹보들 아미네이드들은
>> 그런 적 있습니까?네 네. 그 5월
달 한번 발표하고요.
근데이 호자는 지금 5월 달보다는
주관는 이미 그로 나왔습니다.
>> 지금 포드 피아는 38배 정도 되고
포드 PBR PBR 쪽으로 보시면
15배 정도 돼요. 되게 비싸요.
아우는 28.5% % 정도 됩니다.
어 글로벌 CCR 시장 MS는 15%
1등을 유지하고 있고요. 요리 지물
E클라스 승차 라인 보여하고 있는
글로벌 최대 수치 계열화 회사이고요.
작년 만에이 홍콩 회사는 그 반기마다
실제 발표해요. 그냥 반기 하나 연간
하나 이렇게 하고요. 분기는
없습니다. 뭐 승택할 수 있어요.
네. 한기 해도 되할 수 있고 안
해도 할 수 있습니다. 그 작년말
매출레는 동의 증가하고요. 순위는
동의 증가하고 그 당시 컨설은 14%
좀 상호했습니다. GP 마진
19.5% 5% 나오고요. 동의
1.9% 화대하고 MP 마이 12%
나왔습니다. CCR 그리고 요리
선유동 제품 PQ 돈반 화다에 따라서
허실적 달순했습니다. 그리고이
CCR는 최근는 가격 올라가고
있고요. 원래 초보다는 총 어네 차례
정도가 가격 인상 결정하고 인산율은
보통는 10% 수준입니다. 월별
10%
>> 특히는 5월 말은 10% 인상했어요.
>> 음
>> 다만 6월 10일 6개월는 15%
추가 인상 결승했습니다. 처음 그
15% 인사했어요. 그래서 원래는
누전 68% 주는 인상되었고요. 5월
달 그때 제가 자본 분위가 5월 달은
그렇게 이야기가 나왔습니다. 요리 선
공 공 공급주 부조에 따라서 시 가는
추가 인상 판단 누전는 그 5월 달는
누가 30% 인상하고 연말까지 누전은
50%부터 70% 판단했어요. 그래서
이미 충분히 그이 수준은 넘어갔어요.
음이 CCR 가격은 10%
인상하면은이 회사 GP 마주 8%
선승 가능성이 있어요. 어끝제에는
C시티는 관련 리포트 나왔습니다.
원래 선반이는이 매출에는 동의 증가
수익률는 동의 297% 증가 어 수익
인률는 21.4%로 4%로 동기 대비
두 배 이상화될 가능성이 있고요.
요리 선무 공급좌에 따라서 시가
인상해서 영업 레블리지 효과를
발성하고 원래 하반기 시 가도 강세를
지소 예상입니다. 연간 ASP는
225홍콩달러 정도 되고요. 동의
80%을 선망했습니다. 다만 그월 달
그 현물 가격 분위가 이미 245달로
되었어요. 그래서 환상하면은
238달로
됩니다. 이미 추정치 대비는
올라왔어요.
다만이 문제가 지금 6월- 5%어요.
만약에 7월 10% 8월 10% 연말
가지 월별 10% 하면은이 정체
스토리네.
>> 네. 지문상은 이렇게 됐고요. 왜냐면
다음 달 정도 알 수 있는지 모르니까
10% 가정하면은
어이 추정치보다는
아마 다블로 나올 수도 있어요. 어
CC와 그리고 요리 설명크 동반
화달라서 원래 내년 내후년 EPS는
각각 2.7 3.99 5.4호 위안을
추정되었고 지점 대비 7% 12%
12% 정도 상향 조정했습니다.
내년은 25배피 적용해서 TP는
배홍공달로 제이스였어요. 지전 대비
25%을 상승도 하고 어제 종가 대비
12% 없애 있습니다.이 회사는 3년
CPS CG 90% 정도 되고요.
그래서 PG로 역사를 하면
염증선배밖에 없습니다.
>> 네.
>> 지금 너무 네. 그런 겁니다.
[웃음]
>> 네. 이게 그 이제 회로 기판 관련한
이제 부품이라고 해야 될까요? 뭐
원제료라고 해야 될까? 말 어
재료회사인데
>> 어 여기 중간에 보면은 이제 유리섬류
공급 부족에 따라서 CCL 가격 추가
인상 판단 그래서 이러저로 해서
누적으로 한 50에서 70% 인상
>> 이렇게 말씀해 주셨을 때
>> 아 1년에 50에서 70% 인상하는게
좀 공격적이지 않냐라고 얘기를 하고
싶은데 저희가 뭐 메모리 가격이 뭐
다섯 배 열배 1년 동안 오르는 걸
봤기 때문에 네
>> 어 뭐라고 이렇게 확실한 데이터가
없이는 숫자 숫자만 보고 너무 높다.
이렇게 말씀은 이제 못 드릴 거
같아요.
>> 밑에 표는
>> 아마도 이게 어떤 외국 그 집계 기관
또는 증권사에서의 자료가 아닌가
싶은데 연도별 순위과 EPS, EPS
그로스, PERPBR,ROE 그리고
어 이게 일드는 배당 수익률이겠죠.
네.
어 전형적인 성장주의 이제 패턴인데
그 매출이 늘어나면서 이익이 급증하는
그런 영업 레버리지가 나는 회사로
보여지는데 하나 좀 놀라운 거는
>> 내년 후년 보면은 올해도 그렇지만 어
배당 수익률도 주가가 이렇게 오름에도
불구하고 배당 수익률도 올라가는
그러니까 현금 흐름을 많이 또 돌려
주기도 하는
>> 어 성장주이면서도
3% 4%면은 나쁘지
>> 않죠. 맞아요. 왜냐면 회사는 어
2019년인가 그때부터는 그 케스트
투자들 거의 안 했어요.
>> 어 아니면 그로나시기 후에음이
CC와 각을 저도 그 찾아봤는데요.
역사 최고점은 거의 370달로
됩니다.
>> 음
>> 375달러 그때는 바로 PC 시대
시도죠. 그때보다는 370을 가지고
계속 내려갔어요.
>> 네.
>> 음. 그래서 이거는 연간 우리는 지금
보는 가격은 대충는 200 238
정도 되잖아요. 만약에 진짜 7달
8월 달 월비를 10% 인상하면
여말가지는 370 넘어갈 수
있어요.이
>> 가격.
>> 지금 이쪽으로는 공급 쇼티지 정원을
발성하고 있고 여기서는 어
>> 아직도 그 케스 투자는 케파 투자는
뭐 그 생각이 없어요 아마. 그래서
이거는 정했어요. 이미 그 Q는
정해갖고요. 그래서 P가 인상할 수
있고 그래서이 추정치는
[콧방귀] 약간 아마 좀 보소적으로
출했습니다.
>> 만약까 여기서는 케스 투자는 뭐 그
케파 투자는이 10% 증가하면은 아마
스토리도 박을 수 있고 그래서 성 좀
하나 매월매 좀 지켜봐니다.
>> 알겠습니다. 어이 회사 킹보드
라미네이드.
>> 네.
>> 라미네이트에 직접 투자하는 우리 최턴
분들도 계실 수 있겠지만
>> 맞아요.
>> 한국에 투자하시는 분들이이 기업의
이런 실적 그리고 왕부장님의 전망을
듣고 한국 투자에 응용할 수 있는
부분은 뭐가 있을까요?
>> 두산입니다.
[웃음]
두산도 상황이 비슷할 거다.네
>> 맞습니다.
>> 조금 더 정확히 얘기면 두산의 자회사
>> 그렇죠. 두산 전자 어네 일단 이제
주둔 [웃음]
상장 주식 그리고 우리가 있게 봐야
된다. 그런 말씀 전해드리면서
>> 중국 시장은 여기까지 보도록
하겠습니다. 전일 [콧방귀] 미국
시장 보겠습니다. 우리 유리프로 님
케빈호씨 연설 전으로 분위기가 많이
바뀌었는 거 같아요.네
>> 맞습니다. 어 오늘 출근길에도 많이
보시면서 오고 계실 것 같은데 저도
출근길에 들으면서 왔고요. 이제
그래서 이제 17일 수요일 미국장
먼저 말씀드리도록 하겠습니다. 자,
아마 결과 보시고 이제 많이 보신
표현이 매파적이었다. 뭐 도부
인척하는 독이었다 이렇게 하는 말일
텐데요.
>> 중요한 거는 아무래도이
외파적이었다라는 키워드보다는 어떤
숫자가 이제 나왔고 또 어떤 발언
때문에 시장의 외파적을 받아들였는지
그 기존에 이제 예민해 있던 시장이
그 발언에 이제 왜 그렇게 크게
흔들렸냐를 이제 봐야 될 거 같아서
좀 살펴보도록 하겠습니다. 먼저 이제
FOMC라고 하면은 이제 끝에 시자가
붙어 가지고 이제 회의 체거든요.
그래서 FMC 발표했다라고 하면은
기준 금리뿐만 아니라 이제
성명서라든지 SP 점도표 그리고 뭐
의장의 기자 회견 이렇게 크게
한목금으로 봐야 합니다. 그래서 이제
특히이 중에서도 SCP가 SCP에서
연준 위원들이 성장률이나 실험률 물가
기준 금리를 어떻게 보고 있는지를
보여주는 경제 전망표이기 때문에
이제요 SP가 어제 좀 중요한
요인이기도 했습니다. 이제 전
세계적으로 금리가 좀 상향 조정되고
있는 추세 속에서 그리고 패드
워치에서도 이미 보실 수 있듯이
미국의 기준 금리가 이제 3.5에서
3.75 정도로 유지될 것이다라는
이제 금리의 유지 자체는 좀 예상이
됐던 바였습니다. 다만 이제 문제는
그다음에 방금 말씀드렸던요 SCP
경제 전망표에서
2026년 말에 PC 그리고 근원
PC의 물가 전망 그리고 금리 전망이
좀 상향 조정되었다라는 점이었습니다.
시장이 이걸 이제 연준히 물가를 뭐
끈적하게 본다. 끈적하게 본다라는게
뭐 물가 상승률이 쉽게 안 내려온다.
그또 오래 버틸 거다라고 이제 보고
또 인하 기대가 더 멀어졌다라는
신호를 이제 받아들인 것으로
보입니다. 여기에 이제 기자 회견이
좀 완충제가 됐었어야 되는데 이제
그러지 못했고요. 근데 실제로는 2%
물가 목표에 대해서 뭐 단호하게
유지학보이 단호하게 갈 거다. 그
앞으로 이제 경로를 뭐 2008년에
보낸 이후에 좀 중요한 정책적으로 쓰
정책적 도구로 쓰이던 이제 포워드
가이던스를 통해서 좀 미리
약속하기보다는 앞으로 우리는 시장에서
반응하는 데이터를 통해서 더
판단하겠다라는 메시지를 좀 확고하게
했습니다. 그래서 뭔가 금리 동결
자체가 좀 더 임팩트가 있었다기보다는
인나 기대가 이제 약해지고 있고
그래서 연준이 앞으로 어떻게 우리가
할 것이다라고 좀 가이던스를 주는게
좀 아 좀 줄어든데에 대해서
흔들렸다라고 볼 수 있겠습니다.
그죠? 어제 제가 장을 말씀드릴 때
이제 신용 장고랑 레버리지 포지션이
늘어나서 변동성이 좀 확대될 수도
있다라고 이제 말씀을 드렸었는데 이제
빅스 지수 오늘 같이 보시면 뭐
16.41에서 18.43원 12.4%
4% 정도 상승을 했거든요. 그래서
투자자들이요 FMC 이후에 단기
변동성 확대 좀 준비하고 있는
스탠스가 보인다라고 이제 볼 수
있겠습니다. 그래서 이런 움직임
속에서 이제 주요 지수들 좀 보시면은
좀 크게 하락을 했습니다. 특히
나스닥 100이 1.34%로 가장
크게 하락을 했는데요. SP 500도
이제 하락을 했는데 우측 보셔서 이제
업종별로 보시면 하락의 폭이 좀 더
넓게 넓어졌습니다.
커뮤니케이션 같은 경우가 3%
하락하면서 가장 크게 하락을 했고
자유소비제가 2.7% 하락, 부동산
2.5%, 필수 소비제가 2.1%
정도 하락을 했습니다. 이제 다만
다시 이제 물 주요 지수로 돌아오셔서
필반 지수 쪽 보시면은 올려
1.38% 상승을 했습니다.
>> 음.
어제 이제 5% 좀 크게 하락한
이유도 있긴 했었겠지만 핵심은 이제
시장 전체에 좀 영향을 끼칠 만한
행사의 반도체 지수만 이제 좀 다른
움직임을 보였다라는 점일 것 같은데
연준의 좀 매파적인 스탠스에도
불구하고 상승했다라는 점이 좀
중요하게 봤습니다.
>> 그래서 이제 아래쪽 이동하셔서 좀
반도체 쪽부터 먼저 보시면 마이크론이
2.2% 상승을 했고 AMD가
1.1% TSMC가 1.6%
인텔 3.6% 상승을 했습니다. 우선
번스타인에서 어제 AMD랑 그 ARM
그리고 인텔의 목표 주가를 모두
상향을 했습니다. CPU 르네상스라는
워딩을 썼는데 이제 뭐 알려졌듯이
AI가 체포 중심에서 AI
에이전트형으로 넘어가면서 CPU
수요도 커진다라는 이제 논리를 한 번
더 이제 방점을 찍어줬고요. 그
위쪽에 이동하셔서 빅테크 쪽에 다시
같이 분류돼 있는 브로드컴도 어제
4.4% 상승을 했습니다. 빅테크
쪽에 좀 같이 있기는 한데 브로드컴도
이런 CPU 수요도 같이 커진다. 뭐
칩수요가 같이 커진다라는 이제 흐름
안에서 볼 수 있을 것 같고요. 이제
고객 맞춤형 반도체 칩인 A식을
생산하기 때문에 이제 브로드컴 좀
중요하게 봐야 되는데 이제 어제자로
회사에서 저 뭔가 어 발표가
있었습니다. 어제 2023년에서
2038년 만기의 일부 선수위체를
현금으로 이제 매입한다라는 공개 매수
조건을 발표를 했는데 뭐 총 매입
한도는이자 재외 기준에서 25억 달러
정도 되고요. 뭔가 이게 직접적인
호재라기보다는 이제 기존에 있었던
부채 일부를 좀 조기 상환하거나 아니
재구성 하려는 움직임 정도다라고 볼
수 있을 것 같긴 한데
[목을 가다듬음]
이런 채권 공개 매수를 할 수 있다는
거는 뭐 시장의 브로드컴 현금
흐름이나 좀 재무력을 신뢰하고 있고
회사도 좀 고금리 환경이 유지되고
있는 기조 하에서 부채 만기랑이자
비용을 좀 관리할 여력이 우린라고
해석하고 있는 걸로도 볼 수 있을 것
같습니다. 그래서 또 빅테크 쪽
온김에 이제 다른 종목들도 같이
보시면 메타랑 아마존이 좀 큰 폭으로
하락을 했습니다. 그래서 어제 좀
올랐던 애플도 1.1% 가량 하락을
했는데요. 이제 투자자분들께
벤진가라는 매체 좀 익숙하실 텐데요
금융 매체에서 좀 독점적으로 보도가
있었는데 AI 에이전트 시대에 가장
취약한 기업으로 뭐 구글과 베타가
있다라고 언급을 했습니다. 물론 이제
검증이 더 구체적으로 필요는
하겠지만요 이제 보도에서도 좀 핵심
사항은 AI 모델 자체를 누가 더 막
잘 만드냐라기보다는
AI 에이전트가 뭐 사용자를 대신해서
검색을 하고 뭐 비교하고 클릭하고
예약하고 요렇게 플로우가 있는 시대가
오면은 기존에 있었던 광고 모델이
약해질 수 있다라는 이제 논리를 한
번 더 강화를 했습니다. 그래서 이제
아래쪽에도 살짝 뭐 텍스트로 기재를
해 드렸는데 어제 장에서는 같은 이제
AI 안에서도 플랫폼 광고주랑 인프라
공급주에 좀 향방이 갈렸다. 그리고
앞서 언급 드렸듯이 이제 커뮤니케이션
섹터가 그래서 이제 가장 큰 폭을
하락하지 않았나고 생각을 해 볼 수
있을 것 같습니다. 애플의 경우에도
이제 어제 월전을 하고 팀하고 독점
인터뷰가 좀 있었는데요. 이제 메모리
측인상 언급이 이제 팀으로부터
있었습니다. 뭐 비용 부담이나 소비자
가격 인상이나 수요 둔화 우려로
연결될 수 있어서 주가에 이제 여파를
주었을 것일 텐데 이제 이와 반대로
생각해 보면 반대급부에서 이제 칩
제공들은 가격 인상을 애플에 전가한다
뜻이 되잖아요. 그래서 메모리 병목이
장비주 병목으로 이어지고 있고 해당
밸류체인의 뭐 전반적 상승으로 이어질
수 있다. 그래서 뭐 결국에는 반도체
병목이 다시금 확인된게 아닌가라고 볼
수 있을 것 같습니다. 그래서 사실
아래쪽 이동해서 이제 메모리 쪽
보시면은 어 이런 CPU 관련주들도
상승을 했고 장비주들이 특히
좋았습니다. 그 ASML이 3.7%
상승을 했고 A플라이드 M리얼
4.4% 3% 램리 서치가 1.4%
4% 상승을 하면서 이제 특히
어플라이드 매트리얼스하고 램리 서치는
다시 52주 신고가 쪽에도 이름을
올렸습니다. 이제 전일 나온 시티의
반도체 장비 보고서가 좀 힘을 실어
주었는데요.
>> 반도체 이제 웨이퍼 생산 장비 시장의
강세장이 2028년으로 이어질 수
있다. 그래서 뭐 AM나 렘리서치
그리고 KL요 세 종목의 목표 주가를
모두 상향을 했습니다. 이제 근거는
크게 세 가지인데 TSMC랑 메모리
업체들의 공급 제약 그리고 증설
필요성이 있을 거고 이제 인텔이랑
삼성전자 파운드리 패 진전 그 이제
앞서 또 말씀드렸던 CPU 상승
맥락처럼 이렇게 AI 에이전트형도
넘어가면서 매물이 요구량이 더 커지고
있다라는 겁니다. 무엇보다 이제
보고서의 핵심 문제는 이제 디램
병국이 랜드 수요의 호재다라는
점이었는데요. 이제 디램 공급
부족하고 가격 상승이 겹치면서 랜드
메모리가 오히려 더 활용이 되는
아키텍처 단에서의 변화가 나타나고
있다라는 이제 어 논조가 있었습니다.
뭐 이런 비슷한 맥락에서 이제
하드디스크주들 계속 3일 연속 상승을
하고 있는데 웨선 디지털하고 이제
시게이트 강세랑도 연결이 될 수 있을
것 같습니다.
반도체 외에도 좀 실적 가치성을
키워드로 본다면 좀 매수세가 좀
있었는데 전력이랑 산업제 일부가 좀
버텼습니다. 이제 아래쪽에 적어
드렸는데 그 제너럴 일렉트릭 GE가
1.5% 그 캐터 필러가 1.1%
가량 상승을 했습니다. 그 소프트웨어
쪽에서도 이제 로빈후드가 8.7%
7% 상승을 했는데 이제 개인 투자적
거래 활성화 기대가 기대랑 이제 좀
기술적인 좀 상승세 돌파가 좀 겹쳐진
개별 모멘텀이 계속 이어지고 있다라고
볼 수 있을 것 같습니다. 그도 한번
스페이스 X가 좀 상장이 이후 계속
연속 상승세였는데 오늘은 좀 내리면서
마감을 했습니다. 이제 금리가 좀
높은 레벨 유지하고 밸류에이션이 좀
높으면서 테슬라랑 팔라티어 같은
종목들도 같은 맥락에서 여파가 있지
않을까 장기적으로 봤을 때는 예상할
수 있을 것 같은데 시간으로는 세
종목 모두 상승세긴 해서 좀 이익의
가시성을 키워드로 앞으로 놓고 봐
종목들을 판별을 해야 이제 오늘의
연준 오늘 연준에서 말했듯이 이런
매파적 스탠스 앞으로의 금리 향방에
좀 반응한 결과로도 우리가 좀 새업
들릴다운에서 볼 수 있지 않을까
싶습니다.
>> 음. 어 2부에서 FOMC 부사장님이
더 디테일하게 다뤄 주시긴 할
텐데요. 이제 오히려 매파적 반드
반응이 좀 실적 가시성이 확실한
기업들로의 이목 집중을 더 확인해 준
하루가 아니었나라고 랩업을 드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다. 이상입니다.
[웃음]
>> 제가 왜 웃는 거 같아요?
정리해서
>> 아 정리해서 웃은 건 아니고
>> 어 [콧방귀] 제가 중간중간 이렇게
유리프로가이 정리해 주실 때 어
만약에 일부 이순서를 우리 최부사장이
했다면
>> 네
>> 어 높은 금리 환경을 이길 수 있는
어 기업에 집중해서 투자해야 된다 그
말을 할 거라고 생각했는데 유리프로가
딱 해 주셨어요. 감사합니다. 어
유리프로 아는 분 중에 그 이니셜을
KYM 쓰시는 분 계세요?
없으세요? 유리프로가 뭐 하지도
않았는데 벌써 막 쌍따봉 날리심.
[웃음]
그래서 아이 KY의 K는 우리 김유리
프로니까 아버님이시거나 아니면
지인분이신가는
저 아버지는 데이빗이십니다.
>> 아 그렇구나. 예, 모르시는 분이
그래서 유리프로님이 말씀도 하기 전에
쌍따봉 날리고 시작했습니다. 그만큼
우리 유리프로 [목을 가다듬음] 믿고
보는 일부니까요. 어, 말씀 잘해
주셔서 어, 정리가 쏙쏙 잘 머릿속에
들어왔고 말씀해 주신 것처럼 금리
환경을 이길 수 있는 기업들만 어저께
일부 좀 반등이 되고 전체적으로는
어, SP 500이나 나스 나스닥
종목을 오른 종목 내린 종목을 만약에
이렇게 숫자를 봤다면 내린 종목이
훨씬 많았을 것 같아요.
>> 네. 그래서 그런 부분들이 어제
특징적이었고
어 모두에 말씀 주신 것처럼이 SM
FOMC 미팅 이후에 주가가 좀 많이
크게 흔들렸던 거 같습니다. 2부에서
[콧방귀] 다시 좀 더 보도록
하겠습니다.
아 가상자산으로 넘어가겠습니다. 준혁
주인님 어 어떻게 됐습니까?네 네.
가장자 말씀드리겠습니다. 어제 아까
FMC 성명이 있었던 시간을
찾아보니까 한 3시 반 정도
되더라고요. 근데 그 시간 때부터
나스닥 그리고 다양한 증시들이
떨어지면서 같이 하락하는 모습
보여줬습니다. 그런데 그이 나스닥
선물 같은 경우에는 다시 하락하고
나서 반등을 하는 모습을
보여줬었는데요. 어 비트코인은 그에
맞춰서 반등하지 못하는 흐름 스코에서
보여주고 있다라는 점 말씀드릴 수
있을 것 같고 그런 부분이 계속
아쉬운 거 같습니다. 그래서 어
올라갈 때는 많이 못 올라가고 떨어질
때는 같이 떨어지는 그 흐름이
계속해서 지속되는 것이 봤을 때 어
비트코 가격이 지금 그리고 또
수급상으로도 어 많이 보충되지 못하고
있다. 많이 그 백업되지 못하고
있다라는 점을 요즘 많이 느끼고 있기
때문에 그런 부분들을 좀 참고해서
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 그래서 어
비트코인을 뭔가 저희가 선행적으로 어
증시가 빠지거나 오르는데 어 저희가
가끔씩 어 살펴보는데요. 어 빠질 때
한 번씩 살펴보시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 빠질 때 요즘에 빠지는
재료로는 어 증시와 빠질 때도 같이
빠지기 때문에 그런 부분들 참고해서
보시면 비트 가격에 빠졌을 때 아
무슨 이슈가 있나 보다 이런 생각을
하실 수 있지 않을까 하는 생각을
개인적으로 하고 있습니다. 어
비트코인 장기 차트 보시면 동일한
흐름으로 이어지고 있습니다.
66,000불 정도를 강한 저항선으로
어 작용하면서 갈 확률이 굉장히
크다. 이렇게 말씀을 드리고 있는데
6보를 돌파하는지 어 흐름을 잘
보시면 될 거 같고 계속해서 거기를
돌파하는데 실패를 한다라고 하면 어
옆으로 기거나 아니면 슬슬 내려오는
그런 조정세로 이어지지 않을까 어
예측드려 봅니다. 어 비트코인 리드
인덱스 보시면 아직도 익 익스트림
피어 구간에 있기 때문에 한 22
정도를 기록하고 있다.이 정도는
보시면 될 거 같고요. 비고 현물
ETF 승유출은 미미하지만 11년
정도가 6월 16일 날 기준으로
들어왔습니다. 그래서 어 유출세가
끝난 것은 좋지만 계속해서 이게
퐁당퐁당으로 유출이 들어왔다도 그
유입이 들어갔다도 어 유출세가 조금
크게 들어오기 때문에 그런 부분 저희
좀 유해서 보시면 될 거 같고 어제
그 하이퍼리퀴드의 비트코 아 그 현물
ETF 순유입이 쭉 들어오면서
비트코인 가격이 좋아지는 부분 어
그런 부분 말씀드렸는데 이것도 사실
동일한 거 같습니다. 그 어 비트코인
오히려 비트코인 현물 순 유출이 조금
많이 나올수록 어 비트코인 가격이 좀
안 좋게 작용하지만 이렇게 순
유입으로 돌아섰다고 해서 비트 가격이
확지는 않는 그런 그런 흐름 그러니까
하락의 소재로만 지금 여러 가지
모멘텀들이 작용하고 있는 어
그림이다라고 말씀드릴 수 있을 것
같고요. 어 주유슈 첫 번째로는 제가
제목을 무선주로 자산자산 매입 자금
조달하고 있는 것이 괜찮을까 이렇게
제가 제목을 적어 놨는데 어
strc라는 것이 있습니다. STC의
스트레지가 어 발행한 연구 우선주라고
보시면 될 거 같은데요. 어 25년
8월에 출시하고 나서부터 9월 10월
연속적으로 배당률을 총 일곱 번
인상을 했습니다. 이게 가변
배당률이기 때문에 어 그 회사가 보고
보면서 액면까지가 너무 많이
이탈한다. 그니까 액면가 100인데
100불에서 너무 많이 이탈한다라고
하면 배당률을 임의적으로 조정을 할
수가 있습니다. 그래서 인상을 통해서
어 투자들을 약간 유인하는 그런
효과가 있을 수 있을 것 같고요. 그
현재 배당률은 11.5% 5%가
배당률이 되고 실료 배당 실료 배당
수익률은 12. 12%가 넘어갑니다.
지금 액면가에서 많이 이탈를 했기
때문에 그렇다라고 이해하시면 될 거
같고 어제 아까 말씀드린 것처럼
액면가에서 이탈을 했을 때 회사가
보고 어 배당률을 인상을 하면
투자들을 유인하고 있고 그렇기 때문에
액면가를 이탈했을 때 어 왼쪽 밑
왼쪽에 차트를 보시면 이렇게 밑으로
내려왔다가도 다시 액면가를 복귀를
하는 그런 주가 흐름들을 계속해서
보여 왔었습니다. 어 말씀드린 것처럼
실제 수익률을 계속해서 상승하는
모습을 보여주고 있기 때문에
그렇다라고 보시면 될 거 같고요.
지금 스트레티지가 제가 S1C를
말씀을 드리는 이유가 있는데 어 한번
제가 소개시켜 드린 적이 있었던 거
같지만 MSTR로 자금 조달하는
것보다 스트레티지로 자금 조달 아 그
스 strc라는 연구 손주를 통해서
자금 조달하는게 오래 들어서 더
많아졌다라고 말씀드렸었는데 그리고
뒷받침만한 자료가 오른쪽에 있는
차트입니다. 어 그래서이 오른쪽에
있는게 STRC 도미넌스라고 하는이
노란색 선이 SC 도미넌스인데요.
어, 스트레티지의 우선주들에서 거래가
집중되고 있는 것들이 지금 STRC가
집중이 거의 집중도가 많이 올라오고
있다. 이렇게 흐름으로 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 그래서 비트코 가격은 사실
역설적으로 오히려 안 좋아지고 있는데
어,이 자금 조달하고 하기 위한 그
툴로서 STRC를 더욱 더 적극적으로
지금 하고 있고 어, 총 시가 어,이
가치는 시가 총액은 한 11년 정도
된다라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
그래서 다른 우선주들 또는 MSTR의
보통주를 지금 계속해서 거래를 하면서
어 자금 조달 하기보다 strc라는
툴을 이용해서 어 자금조달 하고 있는
추세다라고 보면 될 거 같은데 그럼이
STIC를 지금 하는 것이 굉장히
안정적인가를 저가 간단하게 살펴보면
될 거 같습니다. 어 지금 작은 운전
시도하는 방식에는 현금이 지금 그
스트레티지가 1 1빌년 정도를 어
보유를 하고 있습니다. 그래서 현재
아까 말씀드린 것처럼 어 이게 1억
400만 주 정도가 되거든요. 1억
400만 주 정도 되고 이거를 배당을
2주마다 지급을 하게 됩니다. 그러면
2주마다 50밀리언씩 계속해서 투입을
해서 지금 배당금을 지급을 해야 되는
거고요. 1년에 1년에 어 STIC
배당금으로만 1.2빌리언가
정도가 어 계속 배당금으로 지급이
돼야 된다라고 보시면 될 거 같고이
모든 거는 현재 액면가 유지가
된다라는 것을 가정했을 때 그리고
현재이 시가 총액이 더 이상 늘어나지
않는다는 것을 가정했을 때이기 때문에
STRC 쪽에서 좀 더 시가 총액이
좀 늘어나고 주식 발행이 좀 더
늘어난다라고 한다면 어이 그 배당금을
지급해야 되는 어 금액 자체는 더
많이 늘어날 수 있다라고 보시면 될
거 같고 현재는 지금 한 7.7년
7년 정도 버틸 거력이 있다라고
합니다. 이거는 배당을 지급하는 어
거 배당을 지급하는 거에서 나오는
수식인데요. 어 예를 들어서
비트코인이 폭락을 하고 어이 사람이
회사들이 지금 어 말하고 있는 어
MNAB 그 어 회사가 지금 갖고
있는 비트코인 대비 비트코인이나
다양한 자산들 같이 해서 지금 주가가
어느 정도 지금 거래되고 있는
MNAB가 급감을 하게 되고 그다음에
방금 말씀드린 STRC가 폭락을 하게
되고 그럼 실질 수익률이 갑자기
급등을 하게 될 수밖에 없거든요.
분명가를 확 이탈하기 때문에 그렇게
된다라고 하면 이제 배당 지급을
실패할 수 있는 확률이 점점 커지게
됩니다. 전환사 전환 사체가 아니기
때문에 어이 우선주에 있는 배당을 어
이번에 못 줄 수 있다. 이런 식으로
그냥 넘어갈 수 있는데 어쨌든 그
지급의 의무가 사라지는 건 아니기
때문에 그런 식으로 계속 데드
스파이를 도면서 뱅크런이 일어날 수
있는 그런 구조로 형성은 되어
있습니다. 그래서 그런 연세 비트
그렇게 예를 들어서 어 배당을 지금
실패한다라고 하면 지금 스트레지가
현금을 만들 수 있는 수단은 MSTR
또는 비트코인 매도밖에 없기 때문에
비트코인을 매도할 수 있는 가치 그
확률이 굉장히 커진다. 그렇게
된다라고 말씀드린 것처럼 계속해서
악순환이 돌게 된다라고 보시면 될 거
같은데 어 지금께서 말씀을 드리고
있지만 26년에는 어 ETF에는 거의
유 유입세가 들어오는게 없었습니다.
춘 어 내로 보게 된다라고 하면 거의
스트레티지만 비트코인을 사 줬기
때문에 비 그 스트레티지가 이렇게
무너진다라고 하면 비트코인의 유일한
수초가 무너진다라고 하는 것. 그리고
MSTR에서는 지금 스 그 연구
우선주 STRC를 통해서 자금
조달하고 있는데 STRC에 대해서
배당을 어 지급하지 못하는 사태가
벌어진다라고 하면 그게 비트코인의
매도 그리고 비트코인의 유일한
수요처가 무너지게 되는 상황까지 나올
수 있다라는 점을 말씀드릴 수가 있을
것 같고 어 하나 고모적인 부분은
스트레티지 해당 이슈가 붉어지고
커지기 전에 이번 하락정이 어느 정도
마무리가 되어 가고 있다는 점이 가장
공무적이라고 생각할 수 있을 것
같습니다. 그래서이 구조 자체는
계속해서 취약한 상태로 넘 그 넘 그
계속해서 이어질 수 있다라는 점은
저희가 기억해서 갈 필요가 있지만
어쨌든 언제나 한 번쯤 한 번쯤 계속
나올 수 있고 계속해서 언급될
이슈라는 것을 저희가 기억해서 가면
될 거 같습니다. 저희가 지금이
하락장이 한 70% 정도 왔다라고
예측을 하면서 가고 있는데 그
부분들이 예를 들어서 지금 이제 한
하락장의 초입이었다. 근데이
이슈가져서 배당급 지금 못 하는 거
아니냐라는 이슈가 계속해서 시장에서
나온다라고 하면 어 3D 입장에서는
어이 데드 스파이럴이 그 장치가 한번
돌릴 수도 있는 그런 흐름이었는데 어
고무적인 부분이 어 스트레티지가
뭔가이 구조가 개선돼서가 아니라
하락장이 어느 정도 끝나가고 있는
부분이 고무적이라 볼 수 있을 것
같습니다. 이게 왜 고무적이냐면
결국에는 비트코인 가격이 좋아진다라고
하면 스 스트레티지나 아니면 STIC
관련돼서 주식 주가가 좋아질 수밖에
없거든요. 왜냐하면 주당 비트코인
가치가 올라가기 때문에 어 사람들이
비트코인 투자하는 것보다 MSTR
투자하면서 그 레버리 효과를 더
노리려고 하는 그런 투자들이 많아질
겁니다. 그래서 어 비트코인 가격
상승이 나온다라고 하면 어 STIC는
그때 다시 한번 약간 안정스러
돌아서게 될 확률이 크지만 현재는
하락장이기 때문에 어 ST 그
MSTR니까 스트레티지 입장에서는 아
좀 버텨보자 하는 추세로 가는 거
같다라는 생각을 개인적으로 하고
있고요. 원래 이더리움 밑에 보시면
에더리움의 DAT 기업인 비트마이는
원래는 그 우선주를 갖고 가지 않고
있었습니다. 근데 6월부터 어 그
BM BMNP라는
그 우선주를 지금 어 출시를 해서
지금 거래가 되고 있고요. 배당률이
한 9.5%로 5%로 여기는 고정이
되어 있습니다. 그래서 어 지금
비트마인이 매 주 지급해야 되는게 한
640 640 어 K 정도가 되는 어
그 배당금을 계속해서 지급을 해야
되고 1년에 한 33m년 정도 지급을
해야 된다라고 합니다. 그래서
이더리움도 그 비트 마인도 그렇고
스트레티지도 그렇고 결국에 지금
자신들의 본주 주주 가치 희석이 너무
많이 되게 되고 있다 보니까 그런
것들을 조금 하락장에서 방어를 하기
위해서 지금 연구 우선주를 통해서
조금 자금 조달 해서 그거를 이제
비트코인이나 이더리움을 매입하는 그런
자금으로 투입하고 있다. 이렇게
해석을 하시면 될 거 같고
구조상으로는 어 주주 가치 희석을
조금 덜 하게 할 수 있는 부분이긴
하지만 어쨌든 연구 우선주에서 지금
연구선주를 팔아서 그거를 지금
비트코인이나 이더리를 매입한 쓰고
있기 때문에 구조적으로 이게
튼튼하지는 않을 수 있다라는 점
말씀드릴 수 있을 것 같습니다.
왜냐면 결국에이 현금은이 주주 환원을
위해서 나오는 현금이 아니라 어 그냥
어쨌든 가산자산을 사기 위한 현금으로
계속 남아 있기 때문에 이런 것들이
계속 어 퀘션 마크가 계속해서 붙어
있는 거 같다라고 말씀을 드릴 수가
있을 것 같고 어쨌든 ST 그
스트레티지도 그렇고 비트마인도 그렇고
어 자기들이 갖고 있는 비트코인이나
이더리움의 가치가 어 자기들의
주가에서 어떻게 연동되는지 이런 걸로
지금 거의 홍보를 하고 있기 때문에
어 비트코인 하락장을 좀 버텨보자라고
하는 추세를 두 기업 보여주고
그래서 재무다 조복한 그렇게 얽혀
있는 어 저희가 봐야 될 것은 어쨌든
스트레지가 그리고 비트마인이 지금이
시장을 어떻게 버텨버텨가고 있는
흐름인가 이런 걸 좀 살펴보면 좋을
것 같아서 오늘 이렇게 준비했습니다.
이상입니다. 어 감사합니다. 시간이
좀 지났지만 그래도 몇 개는 좀
중요한 것 같아서 언급드리고
넘어가려고 하는데요. 어, 비트코인
가격이 지금 유지되거나 하락하는 경우
또는 이제부터 점진적으로 올라가는
경우 나누어서 좀 여쭤 볼게요. 네.
>> 우선 여기서 그냥 한 6만 불 초반,
뭐 5만 불 후반 뭐 이런 데서 그냥
사이드워을 하거나 횡보하거나 아니면
우아양하는 경우에 말씀하신 이런 안
좋은이 악순환 사이클로 들어가서
결국은 파산할 수도 있고 그렇게
이해하는게 맞는 거 같은데.
>> 네. 어 우상향한다고 가정을 했을 때
어 스트레티지 기업 입장에서
캐시플로우 그니까 현금이 회사 안으로
들어오는 경우는 보통 줄 발행하거나
우선 줄 발행하거나 또는 어 갖고
있는 비트코인을 팔거나인데
>> 어 비트코인을 파는 거는 좀 차취하고
>> 결국은 이제 주주가 새로 우선 연구
우선주든 보통주든 어 새로 주주가
들어올 경우에 회사에 이제 캐시가
생기는 거고 그중에 일부는 비트코인
살고
말씀들어
연구선주 가지신 분들에게 분기 아니
2주마다 예 배당을 주시는 거
같아요. 네. 어 그러면 저라면이
우선주를 갖고 있는 주주라면
1년에 한 11% 12% 정도의
배당을 받을 수 있다면 사실은 9년
이내에만 파산이 나지 않으면 원금을
회수할 수 있는 채권이다.
>> 그리고 만약에 그때도 우선주의 가치가
있다면 되 수도 있는 거니까 플러스
알파도 있는 거고요. 어 그런데 그
전에 만약에 망하거나 그러면 우선주나
보통주나 주주기 때문에 이걸 회수
가능성은 이제 없게 되는데음
>> 우선주 주주로 제가 지금이라도 좀
참여하고 싶다라고 하면 결국은
구 그니까 이미 우선주 주주이신
분들께 저처럼 새로 우선주 주주가
되고 싶어 하는 분들이 투자하는
금액으로 배당을 주는
>> 네
>> 약간 돌 돌려막기 어 그런 개념이
이어서 이거는 어쨌든 구조가 안
좋다. 그런 생각이 좀 들고 어 설사
비트코인 가격이 올라가는 흐름을
보인다 하더라도 갖고 있는
비트코인의이 평가 금액이 올라가니까
스트레티지의 시총은 올라갈 수도
있는데 그때 추가적으로 증자를 통해서
생기는 현금 흐름은 계속 비트코인을
앞으로 사기만 한다면 네
>> 마치 좋을 때는 어 투자하고 나쁠
때는 또 증자하고 뭐 이제 이렇게
되는 구조여서 그래서 이거 조주로선
썩 좋지 않겠다 이런 생각이 좀
드는데 어떻습니까?
>> 네. 그래서 지금 최근에이 스트레트
아 그 STRC를 DAT 하는
기업들도 생기고 있거든요. 그래서이
연구 우선주만 사는 모으는 기업들도
생겨나오고 있습니다. 그래서이
구조상으로 어 S strc가
무너진다라고 하면 str만 무너지는
그러니까 스테디에 투자하는 주주들만
무너지는 구조가 아니게 된 거죠.
그래서 어 STRC를 투자하는
사람들을 그걸 그것만 모으는 사람들도
있기 때문에 구조적으로 좀 많이 얽혀
있다. 그래서 이것들이 어 이탈하게
된다라고 하면 연세적으로 하락이 나올
수 있다라고 보고 있는데 말씀해 주신
부분이 어 저는 맞는 거 같습니다.
그냥 이게 서로 폭탄 돌리기 하 있는
거다라고 보기 싶거든요. 그래서 그런
부분들을 저희가
>> 어 어떻게 바라봐야 되는지 사실
저희가 반응을 지금까지 STIC가이
상승장 때 이거를 지금 출시를 하고
나서 하락장을 좀 겪은 거
처음입니다. 했기 때문에 그런 부분들
어떻게 되면 지켜볼 필요는 있을 것
같습니다.
>> 예. 그래서 제가 과거에 이제 우리
준혁주임하고 처음에이 스트레티지
공부할 때 이런 말 했던 기억이
나요. 어, 비트코인 가격이 이렇게
우아양할 때도 계속해서 유상증자를
통해서 스트레티지가 코인을 모을 건데
다시 이렇게 우상향하게 되면
>> 어, 저점에서 모은 그 회사의 내부에
있을 코인 가격의 평가 금액이 훅
늘어나니까
>> 어, 나중에 코인 가격 상승기에 코인
가격 상승한 것보다이 이미 많이 갖고
있는게 같이 올라가니까 어, 주가가
레버리지가 날 수도 있다. 그런
말씀을 드렸던 기억이 나는데 이렇게
계속해서 현금이 세는 구조라면 이거
좀 다시 계산해 봐야 된다. 그런
생각이 드네요.
>> 맞습니다. 그래서 이번에 스트레티지가
이번에 비트코인이 사실 7만 불을 잘
돌파하고 있다가 확 폭락하게 된게
스트레티지가 32개 비트코인을 팔고
나서이잖아요. 스트레티지 그 마이클
세일러 하는 말게 이게 이너큘레이라는
표현을 쓰더라고요. 예방 접종을 미리
했다. 그래서 내가 우리 회사는
비트코인을 팔 수도 있다라는 점을
그런 유연성을 보여주기 위해서 시장에
한번 테스트를 해봤다라는 식으로 거의
장난이다시피
발언을 해 줬는데요. 그리고 어 나는
개인들한테 비트코인 팔지 말라고 했지
기관은 우리가 유연하게 팔 수
있다라는 점을 언급을 해줬습니다.
그래서이 부분을 스트레티지가 그리고
마이클 세일러가인지를 하고 있다는
점은 저도 어 약간 어느 정도 느낌을
받았거든요. 그래서 우리가 정말
캐시플로 그 구조적으로 비트마이 좀
다릅니다. 리트마에는 이더리움을
투자, 이더리움을 스테이킹했을 때
나오는 이더리움의 캐시플로우가
있습니다. 그래서 그렇기 때문에 좀
얘기는 다르지만 네. 그 스트레티지
같은 경우에는 현금 흐름이라는게 기존
사업부에서도 없기 때문에 어
스트레티지 같은 경우에는 비트코인을
팔게 될 구조적으로 팔게 될 수밖에
없을 것 같고요. 그리고 세금
측면에서도 물론 손실을 확정 짓는
거지만 세금 측면에서도 비트코인을
팔아서 가는 그 약간 비트코인을 조금
약간 어 금융적 어 툴로 쓰는 그런
기업이 될 확률이 좀 큰 거
같습니다. 그래서 그런 것들 이번
하락장에서 이렇게 할 수 있다는 점을
보여줬고 그리고 앞으로 다음 하락장이
오거나 그 구조적으로 계속해서 쌓아
나갈 때 어 그런 흐름을 계속 보 한
번씩 보여주지 않을까 한 번씩 파는
모습은 보여주지 않을까 생각은 하고
있습니다.
>> 네. 저처럼 게으른 사람은 코인
투자해야지 하다가 어떻게 해야 되지
뭐 전자계 지감 뭐 이런 것도
있다는데 뭐 이러다가 아예 몰라 그냥
스트레티지사 이럴 수도 있거든요.
>> 그런 분들을 위해서라도 앞으로 좀
꼼꼼하게 잘 챙겨 주시면 도움이 많이
될 것 같습니다.
>> 네. 오늘 일부가 좀 많이
길었습니다. 죄송하고요. 잠시
후부에서 뵐 텐데 오늘 저님 외부
강의가 있으셔서 2부도 어 조금
실망스러우시겠지만 제가 진행하도록
하겠습니다. 일부 함께 해 주신
채무턴 여러분 감사드리고요. 잠시
위부에서 뵙겠습니다. 감사합니다.
>> [음악]
>> เฮ
안녕하십니까 최밀턴 여러분. 행복한
투자 예정을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝
브리프 18일 2부 시작하겠습니다.
일부 말미에 말씀드린 것처럼 점님
지금 외부에서 강의하고 계시거든요.
어 굉장히 여러분들 이렇게 계시는
곳에서 강의하고 계셔서 어쩌면 최미턴
여러분들 중에서 거기가 계시는 분이
계실 수도 있을 것 같아요. 혹시
계시면 댓글에네 [웃음]
남겨 주셔도 재미있을 것 같습니다.
일부 유리프로가 미국 시장 전일
어떻게 진행이 되고 연설도 어떤
내용인지 간략히 말씀 주셨는데
부사장님께 좀 더 자세히
들어보겠습니다.
예. 오늘 아침에 와 가지고 저도음
FMC 성명서하고
아 기자 회견을 봤는데요. 전반적으로
지금 연준의 어떤 변화가 어
대대적으로 일어날 수 있는 어
분위기를 감지를 했습니다.
>> 일단 성명서 보면은
>> 이게 성명서 전문입니다. 음.
>> 이전에 어 파워장할 때는 한 페이지가
이제 까득 찼었는데
>> 네.
>> 어이 이번에 성명서는 상당히
짧아졌고요. 굉장히 간략해졌습니다.
>> 음. 어떤 분들은 이걸 두고 좀
불친절해졌다 이렇게 평가를 하시는
분들도 있는데 저는 오히려 좀 그
간결하게 핵심만 좀 해 놓은 거
같아서 오히려 어 느낌이 좋았습니다.
일단 금리는 동결했고
어 케미노 씨 이분이 그 생산선
증가를 통해서 물가가
어 하락할 수 있다고 얘기를 해
오셨기 때문에
>> 어 이번에 혹시 그런 부분들이 어 그
FMC 성명서나 기자 회견에서
반영되지 않을까라고 생각을 했었는데
그거에 대한 결론은 좀 유하셨고요.
그리고 오히려 좀 중립적인 스탠스로
어 연준에 대한 변화가
어떻게 될 것인지 어 그리고 어 그
일부 어 포드 가이던스라든지 이런
폐지한 부분들도 있고요. 그리고
연준의 입만 바라보지 말고 오히려
시장이 주는 어 데이터에 더 집중을
해라라는 메시를 주셨습니다. 일단은음
금리 동결 내용에 있어서 이제
성명서를 보면은 그냥 노란치 것만
보시면은 생산성에 대한 부분이 있는데
생산성 증가와 자본 투자는 어
강하다는 표현을 했고 또 인플레이션은
여전히 어 2% 목표 달 목표를
위해서 가는 거는 어 여전하다라고
얘기를 하고 있고 지금은 좀 그보다는
높은 수준 진회라는 거를 강조를
했고요.
높은 이유는 에너지를 포함한 특정
부분의 가격 상승 때문이라고 얘기를
하셨고 어 위원회는 물가 안정을
실현할 것입니다. 그래서 물가 안정에
대한 의지는 확보한 걸로
설명이 됐습니다. 그리고 SAP
서머리 오브 에코노믹 프로젝션이
나왔는데
일단 밑에 그 도표를 보면은
GDP가 지난 3월에 비해서
2.4에서 2.2%로 낮아졌고요.
그리고 시험률 같은 경우 지난 3월에
4.4%였는데 이번에 4.3%로 좀
낮아졌습니다.
인플레이션 같은 경우 지난 3월에
비해서 어 헤드라인 PC 같은 경우가
2.7에서 3.6% 6%로 0.9%
9% 포인트가 높아졌고요. 그리고
근원 PC 인플레이션 같은 경우
2.7에서 3.3으로 역시
높아졌습니다.
물가를 높게 이렇게 어 전망을 하다
보니까 올해 연말 기준으로 해서
연방 기근 금리도 지난 3월에
3.4% 정도 한 번 정도 인하할 수
있지 않을까라는
그 기대감을 줬었는데 이번에는
3.8%로 8%로 한 번 정도 인상할
수 있지 않을까라는 좀음 약간의 어
그 금리 인하에 대한 기대
이상으로 어 기대를 꺾고 이제 인상
쪽으로 가는
그런 그 그 시그널을 여기 점표에서
줬다고 보시면 될 거 같고 옆에 이제
점을 자세히 보면은
아 인상 쪽이
아 연내 한 번 인상 쪽이 아홉개 가
찍혀 있고요. 그리고 동결 쪽이 한
여덟 개가 찍혀 있고 인하 쪽이 한
개가 찍혀 있습니다. 그래서
대체적으로 동결 인하 절반 그리고
동결 또는 인하가 절반이고요. 인상이
절반 이렇게 됐고음 키비너시
위원장은이 점덕표를 찍지 않았다고 어
지금 얘기를 했습니다.
어, 기자 회견의 주요 내용으로는
포드 가이던스를 폐지했는데이 포드
가이던스가 앞으로 좀 긴축적으로
가겠다, 앞으로 좀 완화적으로
가겠다. 이런 어떤 어, 시그널을
주는 것인데 그런 시그널을 이제 안
주겠다라고 얘기를 했고요. 그리고 그
이유는
시장이 현재 데이터에 반응할 때 가장
잘 작동하고 연준이 가이던스를 주면
오히려 혼란을 주게 되기 때문에
오히려 시장 데이터에 그 현재
데이터에 더 집중하라는 취지로 어
코드 가이던스를 폐지했다고 합니다.
그리고 다섯 개 분야 테스크포스를
출범시키겠다고 했는데 연말까지 어
프레임워크를
짜서 어 도입할 것이라고 어 설명을
했는데 어 커뮤니케이션하고 대처대접표
데이터 생산성 고용 그리고 인플레이션
프레임워크 이런 식으로 해서 다섯
개의 테스트를 출범시킬 예정이라고 어
얘기를 하고 있고 여기에 뭐 새로운
참신한 인재들을 를 영입을 해서 어
스터디를 하겠다는 취지에 발언을
했습니다.
어 Q&A 보시면은 어 오늘 Q&A가
그 처음이라서 좀 그 익숙하지 않고
좀 낯설었는데 이전에 비해서음
그렇게 뭐 자세한 설명이나 이런
거보다는 앞으로의 연준이 어떻게
변화해
갈지에 대한 방향성 정도를 설명했다고
보시면 될 거 같고요. 어 일단 금리
동결 배경과 현 경제 상황에 대한
평가에 대해서 물어봤는데
[목을 가다듬음] 중동 불확실성에서도
경제가 견조하게 확장 중이고 주택은
제약적이나 이제 주택 시장을 그
감안하면은 현재 금리 상황이
제약적이지만 어 주가 상승을
생각하면은 어 금융 여건은 그렇게
제약적인 거 같지 않다. 그래서 금
주택학 시장하고 어 금융 시장을
생각할 때이 양쪽이 좀 균형적이지
않은 거 같다라는 언급을 했습니다.
그리고 대차대지표 TF에서 어 정책
파급 경로를 어 점검할 예정이다라고
얘기를 했고요. 오늘 발표한 다섯 개
분야 테스코버스 추진 일정에 대해서
물어봤는데 몇 주 내 가동에서 가을
중에 중간 프레임워크를 도출하고 올해
말까지 최종 결론을 내릴 것이라고
얘기를 했습니다. 목표 인플레이션
2%를 수정할 가능성이 있냐라고 했을
때 수정 계획은 없다라고 얘기를
했고요. 물가 목표 복귀 시점을이 시
2028년을 보면 8년으로 보면서
적극적인 조체 없이 관망하는 이유가
뭐냐라고 물어봤는데이 위에 다시가
보시면 그 물가 목표치를
달성하는 시점 자체가 2028년으로
돼 있는데 어 지금 그럼 뭐라도 해야
되지 않느냐라는 취지로 물어봤는데
물가 안정 의지는 확고하지만 다음
회의 전까지 구체적인 정책인들을
제공하지 않을 것이라고 얘기 얘기를
했습니다.
성명서 분량을 축소하고 포워드
가이던스를 전면 폐지한 배경이
뭐냐라고 질문했는데
물가 안정 의지는 확보하고 다음 회의
전까지는 구체적인 정 아 죄송합니다.
시장이 연준인만 바라보는 관행을
없애기 위함이고
어 효율적인 시장은 연준이 아닌 실물
경제 데이터에 직접 반응하도록 할
것이라고 어 얘기를 했습니다. 점도
표상에서 연말 금리 전망을 두고
내부적으로 이견이 있었냐라고 질문을
했을 때 인상하던 쪽과 현상을
유지하자는 쪽이 반으로 나닌 것은
맞는데이는
향후 전망의 차이일 뿐이고 오늘의
동결 결정과 물가 안정 목표에는 만장
일치로 합의했다고 얘기를 했습니다.
[콧방귀] 인플레이션의 장기적 경로와
구조적 압력에 대한 견해는 어떠냐라고
물었을 때 공급 충격으로 유가 등
특정 부분이 상승하고 있고 물가
안정을 달성할 것이라고 다시 어
반복을 했고요. 데이터 TF를 실설
신설한 배경과 대한 데이터 확보
방향에 대해서 물어봤는데 어 정보의
구식 설문 통계는 실시간 경제를
반영하지 못하고 있고 민간
CEO들처럼 오차를 줄인 실시간 동행
데이터 분석 기법을 정책에 도입할
것이라고 얘기를 했습니다.이 이
생산성 향상이 금리하나의 근거가
된다는 생각이 유한지에 대해서
물어봤는데
AI는 큰 혁신이며 미국이 수혜자가
되겠지만 구체적인 정책적 시점 규모
고용 영향은 신설된 생산성 고용
TF를 통해 몇밀히 따져 봐야
되겠다라고 얘기를 했고요. 어, 최근
고용 지표를 종합할 때 현재 고용
시장을 어떻게 진단하느냐라고 질문을
했는데 고용 시장이 안정적이면서
생산성 주도의 강력한 고용 시장은
아, 고용 성장은 어, 두려워할
대상이 아니라 환영해야 될 요소라고
얘기를 했습니다. 그래서 생산성에
대한 몇 가지 어 질문들이 있었고
그에 대해서 어 금리 인하에 대한
근거는 좀 더 따져 봐야 될 거
같다라고 좀 말을 아끼는
상황이었고요.음
기본적으로
그냥 백트 위주에
그 기자 회견이 이루어졌고
어 향후 어 연준의 변화 방향성에
대해서 청사진 정도 제시한 걸로
보시면 될 것 같습니다. 음. 이런
기자 회견 이후에 아, 뭐 좀 약간의
완화적인 스탠스라도 기대하고
있었던 어, 투자자들이 뭐 별거
없네라고 하면서 좀 물량을 던지는
모습이었고요. 음. 반도체 쪽도 좀
상승폭이
둔화되는 그런 모습들이었습니다.
그래서 시사점은 제가 생각을 해봤는데
오늘 만약에 지금 완화적 스탠스가
나왔다라고 생각을 하면은 전반적으로
종목이나 섹터에 확산이 좀 나타났을
것 같은데 어 시장이 단기적으로는
연준의 매파적 센스에 좀 반응을 한
거 같고요. 만약 그 완화적했다면은
섹터 확산이 가능했을 것인데 유가
안정 여부에 따라서 좀 금리가 안정은
되겠지만 약간 좀 매파적 스탠스를 좀
깔고 가는 그런 상황이 될 거
같습니다. 그래서 당분간 높은 금리
레벨의 시장이 적응을 해야 될 거
같고요. 아, 그런 상황에서
섹터 쏠림이 좀 지속될 거 같은데
어느 쪽으로 섹터가 쏠린 건지에
대해서 생각을 해 보면 아까 좀 그
아이 대표님이 웃 웃었던 포인트인데이
높은 금리 레벨로 인해서 익 모멘텀이
강한 쪽하고 그렇지 않은 쪽에
차별화는 좀 계속 이어질 것
같습니다. 해서 현재 가장 강한
모멘텀이 지속되고 있는 AI 인프라
쪽에 모멘텀은 계속 유효할 것이라고
생각이 됩니다. 이상입니다.
[웃음]
>> 네.
>> 예. 예.
>> 어, 내용을 좀 여쭤보기 전에 사단
먼저 좀 드리면
>> 예.
>> 어, 마지막에서 마지막 줄에서 두
번째 줄
>> 높은 금리 레벨론의 이익 모멘텀이
강한 쪽과 그렇지 않을 쪽이 좀
차별화될 거다.
>> 예. 난 이렇게 결론을 내릴 거니까
유리야 일부에서 너도 톤을 맞춰라라고
사전에 말씀하셨어요.
>> 약간 상인는 했었습니다. [웃음]
>> 잘하셨어요.
>> 예.
>> 네. 맞는 말씀인 거 같고요. 어,
먼저 쭉 이렇게 그 [콧방귀] 항상
이렇게 FOMC에서 의장이 이렇게
연설을 하시거나 Q&A를 하시고
나면은 오늘 댓글창에도 그런데요.
어, 이게 말씀하신 것을들을 거냐
아니면 말씀하신 그 이면에 어떤
메시지가 있다고 믿을 거냐
>> 뭐 이제 그런 걸로 항상 어 왈과왈부
말씀이 많으셔서 저도 고민되는데
>> 이게 좀 빚대자면 가이바이보 게임할
때 우리 부사장님하고 제가 가위바이보
한다고 할 때
>> 아 그냥 난 무조건 주먹 낼 거야라고
생각을 했다가
>> 부사장님이
>> 어
>> 보호를 내면 어떡하지? 음.
>> 그럼 난 가위를 내야 되는데.
>> 음.
>> 어, 그 주먹 내면 어떡하지? 그럼
난 보를 내야 되는데. 이렇게
계속해서 꼬리를 물다 보면이 끝이
끝이 없는데. 예.
>> 어. 보통 우리 원문과 음. 직접이
라이브로 들으시니까 그런 행간의
의미를 저희가 생각하는게 맞습니까?
아니면 말하는 그 말을 그냥 맞는
이해하는게 맞습니까? 워 그대로
이해하는게 맞는 거 같아요. 이분
같은 경우는
>> 특별히 이면의 어떤음
외중을 담아 가지고 얘기하는 부분들은
제가 잘 못 느꼈습니다.
>> 음. 그래서 어 일단은 어 지금
연준의 현 상태를 어떤 식으로 좀
고쳐야 되겠다는 의지는 강한 거
같고요. 그 의지를 의지 하에서 좀
빌드업을 해 가는 상황이라고 봐야 될
거 같고
>> 약간 분위기는 어 내가 이렇게 좀
고칠 건데 너무 지금 어떤 답을
달라고 하지 마. 어
지켜봐. 그리고 또 내가 여기서 말할
수 있는 위치도 아니고 또 데이터가
시장데 시장이 어 어떤 데이터
즉각적인 데이터에 반응을 할 거니까
내가 굳이 그걸 말할 필요는 없을 것
같아.요 요 정도의 뉘앙스였던 거
같아요. 그래서
>> 어 그이
FMC 있기 전에도음
그 너무 많은 그 연준의 역할보다는
어 좀 연준의 역할을 좀
축소시키겠다. 아 그런 얘기들이
많았는데 실제로도 좀 그런 스탠스이지
않을까? 음.
>> 그리고 테스프스 다섯 개 만들어
가지고 좀 그 앞으로 어 연준이
나아가야 될 방향성을 좀 재정립하는
그런 과정이 좀 필요하지 않을까? 아
그런 과정에서 아직 뭐가 만들어지지
않았는데
>> 뭘 달라고 하니까 약간 좀 어
질문하고 답변이 동문 서이 되는
경우도 좀 있었던 거 같고요. 예.
네. 그런 느낌이었습니다.
>> 오늘 아침에 제가 뉴스 비으면서
출근하다 보니까
>> 지난번 FMC 미팅할 때랑 지금하고
이제 비교해서 설명을 해 주시면서
>> 지난번에는 9월 9월 달에 금리
인상이 필요하다고 얘기한 의원이
아무도 없었는데
>> 이번에 뭐 거의 다 그렇게 얘기를
해서
>> 9월 금리 인하를 거의 기정 사실로
받아들여야 되는 거 아니냐는 걱정을
시장이 하고 있다라는 기사를 읽어
주시는 걸 들었거든요. 거는요
미팅을 보고 Q&A를 보고 너무
파생된 그 추론이었을까요?
>> 저는 그렇게 생각합니다. 예. 그래서
그냥음 있는 그 지금 그 거의
종전이라고 봐야 되는 거잖아요.
사실상. 그리고 M에 합의했다는
오늘 뉴스도 나왔는데 제가 보기에는
지금은 이렇지만
어 호르무주의 회업이 개방이 되고 어
유가 흐름이 좀 안정이 되게 되면은
물가는 자연적으로 그 유가로 인해서
올랐던 물가는 조금 내려오게 될
것이니까 한 6주 후에
>> 어 스탠스는 조금 바뀌어 있지
않을까?
이렇게
결론을 수밖에 없어. 이런 식으로
되지 않을까? 그렇지만 앞으로는
어떻게 될지 몰라. 또 데이터를 봐야
돼. 앞으로 어떻게 될지 묻지 마.
요런 식으로 되지 않을까 싶습니다.
>> 네.
>> 어 이제 금리를 앞으로 오래 올릴지
내릴지가 봐야 알겠으나
>> 물가 때문에 금리를 보다 보수적으로
결정해야 된다는 톤은 좀 완화가 될
것 같다. 말씀이신 거예. 예. 예.
그렇습니다. 지금 상황만으로 보면 좀
그럴 거 같고요. 아, 지금까지
있었던 어, 불 그 고유과 상황에서
어, 선택은 이렇게 밖에
어, 이렇게 될 수밖에 없지 않았을까
그런 생각이 듭니다. 왜냐면 어 그이
회의를 할 때만 하더라도 뭐 이란과
미국 간의 어떤 합의가 완전히 끝난
상황은 아니었을테니까
약간 좀 그런 부분들이 덜 반영되지
않나 않았나 싶습니다. 그래서 제가
볼 때는이 PC 물가나 코피c 물가가
약간 높게 찍히 높게 추정되지 않았나
싶고요. 지금이 상황에서 아니면 또
며칠 있다가 어 해 보라고 하면이
부분이 조금 더 완화되지 않을까
싶습니다. [목을 가다듬음] 네.
>> 알겠습니다. 마지막 질문인데요. 어
약간 그 복귀를 해 보면 지난주
일요일 날 그 우리 인턴 분들은
보셨을 어 글로벌 인사이트 자료의
일부인데
>> 그 혹시 부사장님 이제 출장 중이셔서
아마 못 보셨을 것 같아요.
>> 예. 보호 내용이 뭐였냐면 아 골든
마스닥스의 펀트 자료였는데
>> 1952년인가요? 그 이후에 어
미국의 10년물 국채 금리가 어느
수준에 있었는지를 x축으로 놓고
>> 어 금리가 어떤 수준이었을 때 앞으로
6개월 동안 SMP 500 주가가
올랐는지 내렸는지를 Y 쪽으로 놓고
이렇게 보니까 어 심년물 고체 금리가
한 4에서 4.5% 5% 보다 높은
구간으로 있으면
>> 어 SMP 500의 향후 6개월
주가가
>> 어 오른 경우보다는 내린 경우가
많아지는 기 시작하고
>> 어 5% 넘어가고 5% 넘어가면 내린
경우가 훨씬 많고 뭐 이렇게 되니까
10년물 국채 금리 보고 어이고
4.5 넘었네. 뭐 이렇게 되면은
저희가 좀 더 민감하게 보는 거
같다면 그런 내용이었는데
>> 요거를 조금 의역을 해 보면
>> 어 금리가 높으면 높을수록 지수
자체가 오른 것에 대한 기대치는
낮아지고
>> 예
>> 어 개별 종목이나 업종에 대해서 보다
면밀한 분석을 통한 투자가 더
중요해진다. 이렇게 그냥 의역해도
되겠죠.
>> 어 당연한 얘기죠. 왜냐면은 어
금리가 뭐 추세적으로 여기서 5%
6% 뭐 7% 갈리는 음
>> 없잖아요. 그리고 어 그렇다고
하더라도 어 여기 4.5% 수준에서
뭐 3.5%로 갈 리도 없고요.
그래서 4에서 4.5% 레벨에서
움직일 것 같거든요. 저도 아 4%를
뚫고 내려가기는 좀 어려울 거 같고
>> 그러면 증시 입장에서는 4에서
4.5%를 어떻게 생각할까? 어
고민해 보면은 그 채권하고 어
주식시장 전체를 놓고 볼 때 좀 어
주식시장 자체 시장 지수 자체에
투자하시는 분들은 좀 고민이 될 거
같습니다. 어, 그렇지만
그 시장 지수 내에서의 종목별 이익
모멘텀은 서로 다르기 때문에 아까도
제가 말씀드렸지만은 그 고급리를
이겨낼 만한 이익 모멘텀이 강한
종목들과 그렇지 않은 종목들이
차별화될 것이기 때문에
>> 어, 필반 취수만 보더라도 올해 이제
거의 90% 100% 이렇게 오른
반면에
>> 어, S&P 500은 10%가 채 못
올랐잖아요. 어 그런 차원에서
보면은이 고금리에
금리가 높은 어 고금리 어 상황에서의
그 포트폴리오 어 운용 능력이 어
사실상 향후에 성과를 자우하게 될 것
같습니다.
>> 네. 그런 과정에서 지금 누가 보래도
AI와 관련되어 있는 어 구경제
신경제를 포함해서 관련한 종목들과
업종들이 시장을 리드하고 있는데 또
지나치게 높은 밸루에이에이션이 됐거나
아니면 모멘텀이 이렇게 피크 아웃하는
구간이 있으면 저희가 또 잘 짚어
드리도록 노력해 보겠습니다.
>> 미국 [콧방귀] 시장 FOMC
케빈오시 의장의 첫 번째 연설이
있었는데요. 관련해서 우리 최부
사장님과 함께 알아봤습니다. 오늘
미국 시장은 여기까지 보도록 하고
한국 시장으로 넘어가 보겠습니다.
우리 고장님 부탁드립니다.
>> 네. 전일 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
코스피 지수 1.6% 상승으로
마감했었고 코스닥 1.3% 가량 상승
마감했습니다. 수급적으로 봐 주시면
개인 투자자가 5천억대 매수세가
유입이 됐었고요. 외국인이 3거일
연속 순매수를 이어오다가 전 일장에는
1조 가량 매도를 했었고
>> 기관에서는 뭐 4일 연속
수매수입니다. 약 6,억 정도
매수세가 유입이 됐었고요. 외국인
선물에서는 한 7,800억 가량 선물
매수가 있었습니다.
투자자별 외양 보면 외국인 투자자는
SK닉스 그리고 삼성 전기, 현대차,
기아, 현대 로템, LIG, DNA
등을 매수를 했었고요. 매도에는 SK
스퀘어, 그리고 HPSP, LG
이노텍, 서진 시스템, 키움 증권,
한미반도체 등을 매도했습니다. 기간
매수에는 SK이닉스, 삼성전자, SK
스퀘어, 한국 조선회양 키움 증권
등을 매수를 했었고요.
매도에는 현대차 그리고 삼성 전기,
삼성 SDI, HPSP, 추성
엔지니어링 등을 매도했습니다. 52주
신고가는 총 17 종목이 나왔는데요.
코스피스, SK이닉스, 그리고 SK
스퀘어, SK 지주사, 롯데 쇼핑,
현대백화점, 코리아 서키트 등이
신고가였고요. 코스닥은 어 작은
종목들입니다. YG1, 예티,
화신 전공 등이 신고가였습니다.음
>> 우리 오늘 오가장이 좀 힘이 없어
보이는 이유가 있습니까?
>> 아, 최근에 몸살이 좀 있었어 가지고
>> 네. 어, 젊지만 긴팔 입어요.
>> 알겠습니다. [웃음]
네. 에어컨으로부터이 멘탈을 보호해야
됩니다. 예. [웃음]
어. [콧방귀] 어, 제가 최근에
이제 그 오과장이 정리해 주시는
투자자별 매매 동향 보는데 여기
보시면 이제 기관의 매매, 매수상위
종목들 중에서도 ETF가 좀 많이
눈에 띄는데 그렇지 않은 개별
종목들도 이게 다 ETF 때문에 사고
파는 것 아닌가 하는 생각을 많이
하는데 그렇지 않아 보이는 종목들이
좀 보이세요? 그니까 ETF에 ETF
매매 때문에 개별 종목 매매가
일어난게 아니다라는
느낌의 종목이 있으세요. 조선주들이
좀 그런 거 같고요. 집어서 사는
경우 외국인들도 그런 경우 좀 있었고
>> 음
>> 다른 건 딱히 없는 거 같습니다. 뭐
>> 자동차나 이런 것도 뭐 자동차
ETF를 활용하는 투자들도 분명히
있을 거고
>> 음
>> 그래서 요즘 대표님 말씀하신 것처럼
ETF가 좀 시장을 지배하고 있는
느낌 반도체 소부장도 약간 그런
느낌으로 들어오는 거 같거든요.
수급들이
>> 음
>> 알겠습니다. 밑에 신고가 종목은 우리
선구대리한테 제가 하나만 좀 여쭤보고
넘어갈게요. 어 뭐 하이닉스 S
하이닉스 때문에 스퀘어도 좋고 SK도
좋고 다 그런 거 같아요. 그런
부분은 그냥 바로 다 직관적으로
이해가 되는데 우리 지난주가 지진한
중간의 우리 유통 기업들 그 박스리
시간을 좀 얘기했는데
[목을 가다듬음]
어 롯데 쇼핑 현대백화점 그리고 여긴
없지만 신세계 이런 것들에 어
[콧방귀] 주가가 좋은 것 중에 상당
부분의 지분율이 아마 외국인들이
한국에 와서 소비하는 것 백화점
매출을 일으켜 주는 것인데
그런 부분들이 밸루에이션을 보면은
어느 정도 좀 반영이 됐다고 봐야
될까요? 아니면 상당 부분 기대치가
좀 남았다고 봐야 될까요?
어, 제가 그때 박에서 말씀드렸던
내용은 사실 외국인들의 어,
효과보다이 국내에 있는 내국인들의
>> 어, 수퍼가 훨씬 더
>> 죄송합니다.
>> 말씀을 드렸었는데
>> 어, 거기에 더불어서 아무래도
외국인들의 그 실링이 좀 위로
올라가다 보니까
>> 지난주에 그 3사 다 콩을 진행한
걸로 알고 있거든요. 꾸를 진행했을
때 이미 하이싱글까지 외국인들이
비중이 올라왔다라는 그 콘크를
하자마자 주가가 더 탄력받고 올라오는
모습입니다.
>> 네. 자, 그 박스리 할 때 외국인
매출 비중이 14%인가 그런 예,
차트가 있었던 기억이 제가 머리 확
박혀서
>> 어, 우리 박스 내용을 제가 잠깐
오해했었나 봐요. 한국은 7% 내외인
걸로 알고 있는데 일본 사례를 보면은
13% 정도까지 올라갔다라는게
내용이었었고
>> 다만 일본이랑 좀 달랐던 거는 한국은
로드샵 비중보다 백화점에서 명품을
파는 비중이 훨씬 더 높기 때문에
그게 한국만의 유일하게 좀 특징이라고
하더라고요.
한국은 13%보다 더 비중이 높아지게
가능성이 높다라는 의견을
전달드렸습니다. 일본 같은데 가보면
명품 브랜드샵들이 길에 이렇게 시내
중심가에 보면 있는데 한국은
>> 뭐 청담동이나 그런데 일부만 일부
아니면 거의 못 본 거 같아.
맞습니다.
>> 그래서 관광객들이 오게 되면은 명동을
많이 가잖아요. 명동에는 그런
로드샵이 없어요.
>> 음. 없죠.
>> 네. 없어요. 다 백화점이라서 아마도
그런 어 매수 수요가 다 백화점에서
일어나는게 아닌가라고 저희가 생각을
해 볼 수 있을 것 같고요.
>> 외국인 비중은 1분기 기준으로 한
4% 정도였어요. [목을 가다듬음]
그리고 100%점 네. 거의
대체적으로 비슷한데요
>> 정도였고 최근에 올라오는 속도가 이제
한 5월 달 기준인가 그게 이제 한
7%까지 올라왔어요.
>> 네. 7%까지 올라왔고 지금 현재
속도로 보면은 올해 연말 되면은 이제
두 자릿 수까지 올라올 수 있지 않다
이렇게 지금 예상을 하고 있습니다.
>> 네. 그게 어 백화점 34가 PR
기준으로 뭐 15배, 20배 이런
거는 본 적이 있었나? 한 20년
전에 있었어요.
>> 잘 못 본 거 같아. 예. [웃음]
그래서 익숙지 않은데 여기 실적을
꼼꼼히 체크해야 요런 식 요런
밸루에이션에서도
>> 어 이제 속 이제 손이 나가고 보유할
수 있을 것 같습니다. 저희가 반도체
그리고 그와 관련되어 있는 밸류체인에
가장 많은 관심을 두고 있는 건
맞는데
>> 어 다른 이제 기관들이나 개인들
보면은 그 이외의 포트폴리오에서도 꽤
좋은 성과를 기록하고 있는데 요통도
그런 업종 중에 하나가 또 되지
않나는 생각이 들어서 여쭤봤습니다.
넘어가 보겠습니다. 다음 진행
부탁드립니다. 과장님.
>> 음. 반도체 소부장 섹터 말씀드리면
어제 대형 반도체 쪽에 삼성전자가
1%대 올랐고요. SK하이닉스가
5.8%
강세 흐름을 보였습니다. 최근에
하이닉스의 주가가 어 전자보다 좀
상대적으로 많이 강한 느낌인데 뭐
ADR 상장이 눈앞에 있다라고 볼
수가 있겠고 또 내년 HBM에 대한
가격 결정이 한 7, 8월 경에
나온다고 들었는데
>> HBM의 노출도가 큰 하이닉스
쪽으로의 좀 더 매수세가
>> 강하게 나오고 있는게 아닌가? 네.
그런 생각이 듭니다. 근데 또 보니까
하이닉스가 전자의 P수는 또
뛰어넘었더라고. 네.
>> 이런 말씀을 아침에 드리면 몇뭐
일주일 정도면 또 전자가 따라잡기 뭐
이런 식으로
>> 좀 왔다 갔다 하는 경향이 있는데
어떻게 될지 좀 지켜봐야 될 것
같고요.
>> 네. 아래 소부장 쪽은 요즘에 좀
혼조세인 거 같아요. 뭐 어디가 많이
올랐다라고 하면 다른데 좀 빠졌다가
또 반대로 그다음 날은 움직이기도
하고 이런 흐름이 나타나는데
HPSP가 한 5% 가량 빠졌습니다.
최근에 뭐 상한가도 가긴 했었는데
저도 뭐 연구님들한테 좀 물어보고
했는데 제가 알기로는 테라 이슈밖에
없는데 이게 뭐 다른 이슈 때문에 또
올라가는게 있냐라고 어 물어봤는데 뭐
없다고 하더라고. 음.
>> 그래서 그냥 뭐 젠슨 가서 LG
관련주도 올랐던 것처럼 약간 시장이
워낙 화랑이다 보니 작은 호재에도
민감하게 반응했던게 아닌가 그런
생각이 들고요. 그리고 아래 장비주
쪽 이오테크나 뭐 파크 시스템 지금
원익 IPS 이런 종목들 대체로
좋았던 거 같고요. 기판 쪽에서는
심택 2.6 뭐 대덕 전자 2.5%
상승세를 보이면서 키판 업종도 나쁘지
않았습니다. IT 섹터에서 전기는 좀
약한 모습이었는데 LG 전자나 LG
이노텍 상승세를 보였고요. 플랫폼
섹터는 네이버가 0.6%가량
상승세를 보였습니다. 그리고 니케이
지수 전일장이 0.7% 7% 가량
상승세를 보였는데 여기도 반도체가
너무나 좋습니다. 도쿄 일렉트론이
2.5% 올랐고요. 어 무라타가 3%
뭐 호야나 디스코 2비덴 대체로 다
강한 흐름이었습니다. 그래서 이비덴의
포워드 밸류가 90배까지
올라왔고요. 장비주 쪽은 뭐 대부분이
한 40배 이상에서 거래가 되고 있는
거 같습니다. 그런 기준으로 보면
국내 소부장 업체에서 아직 좀
메리트가 있는 종목들도 남아 있지
않나? 라는 생각도 듭니다.
배터리 체인에서는 LG 에너 솔루션이
1.3%
오음새로 마감했고요. 나머지 조목들은
큰 움직임 없었습니다. 뭐 자동차
섹터 어제 쉬어간 흐름이었는데요.
현대차 기아 어 나머지 종목들도
대체로 부진한 흐름이었고요. 소비제
섹터는 뭐 혼조세였습니다. 올랐던
종목들도 있었는데 클래시스가 3.7,
파마 2.3, 휴제리 한 7% 가량
급등세를 보였고요. APR도
좋았습니다. 어제 피부 미용기나
이쪽은 좀 괜찮았었다라고 볼 수 있을
것 같고 음식료 섹터는 뭐 매수세가
여전히 오진 않고 있는 거 같은데요.
농심 약색을 3명시품은 고합 정도
상승률에 그쳤습니다.
조선철감미 기타 섹터는 조선주 굉장히
좋았습니다. 어제 뭐 특별한 이슈는
없었고요. 현중 그리고 하나 오션
하나 엔진 다 올랐는데 하나 엔진의
상승세가 가파르게 나타났습니다.
가장 많이 빠지긴 했었거든요. 엔진이
조선주 내에서
>> 어
>> 차트를 보니까 엔진 모멘텀으로 올랐던
주가 다 빼 버렸기 때문에
>> 밸류에이션도 20배 미만으로
내려갔었고 하다 보니
>> 저가 매수세가 유입이 됐던 거
같습니다. 아래 철강화학 섹터는 좀
부진했었고요. 당산주에선 하나 여로가
3.5% 올랐고 넥스 현대 로템은
약세였습니다.
어 어제 이제 방산 관련된 이야기
나눴을 때 X1에과
라인 메탈이 이제 협업한다라고 말씀을
드렸잖아요. 근데 청궁2까지는
L넥1의 영향력이 큰데 LSAM으로
넘어가면 하나로와 하는 시스템의
영향력이 커지거든요. 이제 li
X1은 그 미사일 시스템을 총괄하는
역할을 하는 거고 어 [콧방귀]
하나 에로스페이스 이제 발사체 쪽 탄
요런 쪽을 이제 주로 하고 있는데
LSM로 넘어가게 되면 고도잖아요.
발사체의 역할이 상당히 중요해진다.
그에 따라 향후의 하나로나 하나
시스템 쪽으로도 기대할 부분이
있다라고 생각이 들어서 뭐 넥스이
이런 천국 모멘텀이나 LSM
모멘텀으로 오른다라고 하면은 결국에
그다음엔 또 하나 여로가 좀 따라가는
흐름이 나타날 수 있기 때문에 그런
부분 좀 참고해서 봐 주시면 될 거
같고요. 바이오섹터는 삼성
바이오로직스가 2.8% 올랐고
에피스는 약법근 수준이었습니다. 어제
코스닥의 바이오 관련주들이 상당히 좀
좋았던 거 같은데요. 또 정부 정책
코스닥 활성화 정책 이런 얘기가 좀
계속 나오더라고요. 그런 영향이 일부
있었던 건지 알테오젠이나 ABL
바이오트론 DND 등이 상승세를
보였습니다.
어 그리고 은행주는 어제 KB 금융이
좀 약세였고요. 증권주도
좀 많이 약했습니다. 5.4% 가량
하락으로 마감을 했고 엔터 쪽은
하이브가 5.6
그리고 JP, YG 등이 상승세를
보이면서 멘터 쪽도 최근에 조금 도는
흐름이 나타나고 있습니다. 그래서
아래 변화기 쪽도 뭐 나쁘진 않았는데
현대 일기 보합 나머들은 대체로 약세
흐름을 보였습니다. 그래서 엔터 쪽이
지금 백화점이나 면세 체인보다 밸류가
낮습니다. 하이브를 제외하고 YG나
>> SMGP
>> 지금 신세계가 17 18배 거래가
되더라고요. 그래서 유통 업체
대비로도 [콧방귀] 지금 밸류가 낮고
저 위로 올라가서 보면 삼양식품도
>> 유통 체인보다 지금 밸류가 낫습니다.
14배 이렇게 되기 때문에 지금
백화점은
약간 반도체 관련주로 엮긴 느낌이
반도체 주가 올라가면 시장 좋으니까
투자자들 돈 많이 벌 거고
>> 그럼 백화정 가서 돈 쓸 거야. 아,
소득 효과. 네. 그런게 그까 아마
박스에서 이런 내용이 아마 다뤄진
걸로 알고 있는데
>> 어, 그런 부분에서 좀 차별화가
[콧방귀]
있는 그래서 사실 실정만 놓고
안정성만 놓고 보면
사시품 같은게 더 좋은 선택지이긴
하면 시장이 생각하는 거는 좀 모멘텀
플레이어들이
더 많은 거 같다. 그런 생각들.
반도체 주식에 묻으면 빠르게 수익이
나니까 소비할 것도 안 하고 다
반도체 주식에 넣는다던데
[웃음]
>> 뭐 일각에서선 팬티까지 팔아서 반도체
사야 되 이런 얘기합니다.
>> 그럼 역소득 거 아니에요? [웃음]
>> 개개인이 다르겠죠. 개개인이
다르겠지. 예. 생각이 다 다르고 또
반도체 너무 올라서 무서워하시는
분들도 계시고 어 아니다 이제
시작이다 그런 분도 계시니까
>> 각자의 상황과 판단이 다를 것
같습니다. 어 오가장 최근에 그
이렇게음 주가 흐름 말씀해 주실 때
보면 어 저는 아 이런 얘기를 요즘
오가장이 좀 안 한다라고 생각했던
부분이 뭐였냐면 어 삼성전기 같은
것들이에요. 삼성전기 같은 것들
실적을 조금 더 디테일하게 보면이
표에서 보여 드리는 것과 밸류에이션이
좀 달라질 순 있는데 뭐 여덟 배
그런데 무라타도 50배 그 어느 전
세계 어 종목들보다 실적이 너무 안
나와서 PR이 높게 보이는 그런 종목
빼고 실적을 동반하면서 멀티플이
높아진 종목 중에서는 뭐 지구 1등일
수도 있을 것 같은데 아닌가 너무
가인
>> 그런데
>> 어 오가장이 보통 이러면
면은부담스럽다.
이렇게 또 한번 코멘트 해 주는데 어
그런 말 요즘 조금 적어진 거 같아.
>> 제가 좀 선호하해서 그런 것도 있는
거 같고요.
>> 아 그래요? SDI랑 똑같은 거요?
>> SDI는 선호하진 않고 그 밑에서 좀
잡아서 먹어 보려는 노력을 많이
하는데 좀 잘 안 되고요.
>> 전기는
>> 어제 한경 나가서도 말씀을 전기에
관해서 좀 드렸었는데
>> 네. [콧방귀]
MLCC 제가 개인적으로 추정해 본
결과로는 어 삼성전기가
1분기 기준 확정실적 기준 MLCC의
계단 가격이 지한 5원 정도 됐거든.
근데 아직 가격 인상이 안 나타났다는
거예요. 그럼 이제 분기별로 24
3년부터 봤을 때 거의 가격 인상이
없었거든요. 근데 이제 쇼티지가
시작됐고 가격 인상이 일어나게 되면
>> 과거 사례로 봤을 때 이제 코로나
때까지 제가 한번 쭉 과거까지 봤는데
IT 수요 만 MCC 수요
쇼티지였잖아요.
>> 그때도 한 30% 정도 가격이
올라갔었거든. 한 1년 반에서 2년간
가격 쭉 올라갔는데 아직 가격 인생
시작도 안 했다는 거죠. 근데도
실적이 지금 잘 나오는 상황이고
그래서 내년에 예를 들어 한 7원까지
한 6.7원 7원 정도까지
올라간다라고 가정을 해놓고 추정을 해
보면 영업 MLCC 사업부의 예상
영업 이익이 2조 정도 나와. 2조에
무라타 밸류에이션 55배를 대입해서
보면 거기서만 110조의 MLCC
가치가 나온다. 근데 뭐 거기서 이제
플래시 BJ나 카메라 모듈까지 제가
어 SOTP로 해 본 결과 한
180조 정도의 시가 총액까지는
>> 음
>> 열릴 수가 있다.데 이제 [콧방귀]
한 가지 좀 위험이 밸루에이션이
위험한 거는 무라타 55배나 이비된
90배를 대입해서 한 건데 업항이
꺾이면 아니면 저희가 생각하는 것보다
단가가 인상 속도가 느리다라고 하면
기대감에 90배 55배 받는
거잖아요. 순식간에 확 꺾일 수가
있거든요.
>> 음. 그런 부분은 좀 위험하지만
아직 가격 인상이 시작도 되지 않은
구간에 그걸 걱정하기는 조금 아쉽지
않나
>> 생각이 들어서 전기는 여전히 좀 삼성
하이닉스 삼성 전기이 세 개는
반도체를 좋아한다면 꼭 보면서 가야
된다.
>> 그런 생각
>> 준비된 답변이었습니다. 음. 우리장님
평가를 좀 해주는
>> 아니 저 이제 미국만 전담을 하다
보니까
>> 네
>> 자세는 안 봤는데
옛날 기억들이 좀 있어요. 그니까
옛날에 이제 삼성전기가 훨씬 잘 나갈
때 잘 나갈 구간이 있었는데 그
IR에서 들었던
얘기들 중에서
그런 얘기를 하더라고요. 삼성전기의
문제가 아니라 업항이 워낙 좋다
보니까 레번지가 나타납다.
>> 음.
>> 예. 그래서 저는 볼 때 이제 두
가지를 보는데 시장의 어떤 성장성 그
기업이 속한 업항의 성장성하고
어 그 기업의 경쟁
>> 어 요런 것들을 좀 보는데
>> 음
>> 그이
그걸 감안을 했을 때이 88배가
땅한가? 음.
>> 어, 요런 부분들 좋긴 한데
>> 아, 좀 과진 않은가?
>> 음.
>> 이런 고민은
>> 잘 몰라. 모르는 입장에서
>> 되더라고요. 예. 그래서이
반도체가 이제
향후 어 그 이익 모멘텀을 감안을
해서 삼성삼자 SK하릭스
마이크론까지 해서 한 6배 7배 한
10배 뭐 샌디스크 한 10배
내외에서 이렇게 거래가 어 되는데
88배를 받는 어 삼성 전기하고
어 메모리 쪽을
월질해 볼 땐 과연 어느 쪽에 더
투자 매력이 있을까라고 생각을 하면
이게 뭐 오로나띵이 아니라 어 그냥
해기를 한다면 음
>> 어 저는 여전히
>> 시클리컬의 성격을 이이냐 아니냐에
대한 어 논란은 있지만 그럼에도
불구하고 저는 좀 메모리 쪽을 음
>> 어 조금 더 선호하지 않을까 생각을
합니다. 네. 우리 오거장이 어 왜
삼성전기를 조금 좋게 보는지에 대해서
조금 논리적으로 설명해 주셨을 때 그
논리가 깨칠 수 있는 부분도 언급을
해 주셨어요. 보니깐 어 이제 일본의
그 탑티어 종목들을 순환 참조해서
이제 간 부분이 있기 때문에
>> 그들이 내려오면 이제 마찬가지로 순환
참조해서 내려오는 거죠. 네. 그래서
그런 부분들은 저희가 잘 보면서 이제
투자를 해야 될 것 같습니다.
>> 알겠습니다. 이제 준비해 주신
리포트로 넘어가 볼까요? 유통 쪽
가져왔는데
>> 아 유통이 마침 있었네. 네. 백화점
3사업 구조 개선 효과가 좀 일어날
거다라고 보는 거 같은데요. 하나
박종대 연구원 자료였습니다. 백건
34 사업 구조 개선으로 영업 이익
10% 증가 효과가 일어날 것으로
보고 있는데요. 어 3 4의 이익
개선과 밸루에이션 상승에 의한 주가
모멘텀을 모두 기대할 수 있는
상황이다.이 가운데 이익선는 주식이나
부동산 임금 상승 등에 의한 부회
효과와 외국인 인바운드에 의한
신규수요 영향으로 구분을 할 수가
있겠고요. 추가적으로 개별 기업들의
사업 구조 개선 효과 또한 적지는
않다. 26년 백화존 3사 연결
영업익 예상 증가율은 컨센 기준으로
39%로 전망이 되는데이 가운데 약
10% 포인트는 사업 구조 조정에
의한 것으로 분석이 된다라고 하고요.
롯데 쇼핑 먼저 이야기를 해 주셨는데
저효율 전포 스크랩 등으로 영업익
5% 증가 효과 나타나지 않을까라는
전망이고 롯데 쇼핑은 현 백화점
사업에서 마산점과 뭐 분당점 등 저율
점포를 연간 개씩 스크랩하고 있다라고
하고요. 올해도 연간 50억 원의
이익 개선 효과를이 부분에서 기대할
수가 있겠다. 그리고 이커머스 사업
역시 철저히 수익성 위주로 전환이
되고 있다라고 하고 고정비 축소나
카테고리 믹스 개선 광고 수익
고도화를 통해 영업적자 규모는 25
290억 적자에서 올해 150억 적자
정도로 추소될 것으로 전망했습니다.
이외에도 고정 비절감에 따른 영업
레버리지 효과를 기대할 수 있는 사업
부분들이 존재한다라고 하고 대형마트는
백화점이나 슈퍼와의 통합 소싱을 통해
매출 총익률 개선 이어나가고 있다라고
하고요. 홈쇼핑은 연간 3,600억
정도에 달하는 송출 수수료가
25년부터 정체되면서 입폭이 증가되고
있다. 컬처웍스는 코로나1 이후
인건비 부담이 크게 줄어들었다라고
하고요. 영화 시장 회복 영양으로
가파른이 개선세까지 보이고 있다.
다만 식품 온라인 사업 제타 출시
영향으로 하반기 영업 손실이 확대될
것으로 보여진다라고 하고요. 불확실성
요인으로 작용하고 있다.이 부분이
이야기를 했습니다. 신세계에도
이야기를 했는데 본전 리뉴얼 효과
등으로 영업 이익 10.6% 6%
증가 효과가 기대가 된다라고 하고요.
어, 먼저 본점 리뉴얼 기조 효과가
좀 크다라고 보고 있는데 전년도
4월부터 11월까지 본관 70%
공간에 대해 영업을 중단을 했다라고
합니다. 어, 전년도 11월 제오픈
이후 올해 6월까지 yy 60%
수준의 매출 성장세를 기록 중인
것으로 보여지고요. 아울러 면세전
관련 불확실성도 크게 완화가 되고
있다라고 하는데 연간 500억 이상의
영업 손실 기록하던 인천공항 DF2
사업을 지난 4월에 중단했었다라고
합니다.
>> 음. 백화점 체인 굉장히 주가 최근에
좋기도 하고 뭐 밸루에이션도 많이
올라온 상황인데요.
>> 이전에 백화점 유통 체인 말씀드릴 때
이제 그 긴시 계열의 신세계와 현대
백화점 예 밸루에이션 테이 그
테이블을 블룸버그 자료로 보여 드린
적이 있었는데
>> 과거 우리 백화점의 밸류 상단은
16배 17배였거든요.
기간이 어느 정도 기간이
>> 그 그
>> 20년
>> 2010에서 한 14년
>> 정도 최근 10여년 동안 네네 근데
그 구간 중에 가장 높았었던 때가 그
중국 관광객이 굉장히 많이 좋았던
시기였는데
>> 그때 17배 수준이었고 지금 현 지금
신세계 기준으로
PR이 한 17배 됐거든요.
>> 어 저번에 제가 말씀드렸을 때가
13배 뭐이 정도였던 거 같아.
그래서 그때는 업사이드가 그래도 3,
40% 정도 남아 있는 거 같다라고
했는데 지금은 일단 과거 사례만 봤을
땐 밸루에이션 상단에 딱 찍혀 있다
생각이 들거든요. 근데 앞으로 그러면
어떻게 해야 이제 주가가 더 올라갈
수 있을까라고 보면 어 추정치이 잘
나와야 된다라 잘 나와야 컨센서스가
사용 조정이 되면서 밸류에이션이
떨어질 것 같은데 사실 그 부분은
이제 매달 신세계는 실적 발표가
나오거든 보니까 5월 달 실적이
굉장히 좋았어요. 그래서 그런
추정치들이 또 이제 반영이 되고 있는
거고 사실 밸류에이션이 여기서 20배
이상 이렇게 가는 건 전 개인적으로
어렵다라고
>> 아
>> 딱이 정도 밸류에서 컨센서스 사용
조정되는 만큼
>> 국가가 움직일 수 있지 않을까? 데
또 모멘텀이 요즘에 들어오면
밸루에이션 무시하는 경우도 많기
때문에 일단 사과될 수도 있거든.
그러면 뭐 그 이상으로 뚫을 순
있겠지만 어쨌든 유통이고 일본
사례에도 저번에 제가 가져왔는데 일본
기업들조차도 한 19배 20배가 딱
고점이었고
>> 음
>> 그래서 그런 걸로 보면음 일본은 또
우리보다 내수가 훨씬 탄탄한 나라
중에 하나인데도 불구하고 밸류가 그
이상 확장이 안 된 걸 보면 어
여기서는 이제 밸루에이션으로 크게
먹을 놈은 많이 없을 수도 있다.
그런 생각을 개인적으로는 좀 하고
있고요. 아래표를 보면 신세계 어
주가와 이제 EPS 추인데요. 확실히
오른쪽이 현대 백화점과는 다르죠.
현대 백화점은 최근 실적에서
나왔다시피 지누스의 적자가 좀 크다
보니까
>> 이익이 백화점 쪽은 나쁘지 않은데
진우수가 많이 깎아먹고 있다.
>> 이거 알 수가 있고요. EPS
추정치가 정말 급격히 사용 조정이
되긴 했어요. 신세계 기준으로 보면.
그래서 이게 계속 계단식으로 올라갈
수 있는지 그 부분을 매월 체크할 수
있기 때문에 한 그 신세계는 그
부분을 좀 참고를 많이 하시면 될 거
같고요. 그리고 아래 이세탄
미치코시의 매출 증가율과
>> 네
>> 영업 이익률인데 이건 대신 증권
자료를 제가 참고를 했고요. 일본
기업입니다. 일본 백화점차에 있는데
중국 관객이 22, 23, 24,
20 쭉 많이 들어왔거든요. 음.
선간의 추세를 보면 굉장히
좋았었다라는 걸 알 수가 있고 오른쪽
비슷한 미치고시의 주가 방일 외국인
수도 어 트렌드가 이렇게 올라갔던
흐름에 주가와 밸루에이션 실적 모두
같이 올라갔었다라는 걸 알 수가
있고요. 최근에 일본으로 가는 중국인
관역이 뚝 떨어졌기 때문에 그 부분이
이제 한국으로 몰려들어오고 있다.
>> 그렇게 좀 봐 주시면 될 거
같습니다.
>> 감사합니다. 그 실적과 멀티플이
동시에 상향되면서 주가가 급이 뛰는
구간이 이제 지나가고 있는 것 같고
>> 실적에 따라서 따박따박 마치
삼양식품이 수틸 지표 보면서 따박따박
올라가는 구간 이제 그런 구간을 우리
요거장은 예상하시는 거 같아요.네
>> 맞습니다. 3형식품도 뭐 분기
100% 서프라이즈 이렇게 났음에도
불구하고 밸류에이션이 20배 위로 못
올라가거나 올라가다 데려오거나
그랬거든요. 음. 그래서 그런 걸
보면 유통이나 면세 백화선인도
비슷하지 않을까?
>> 알겠습니다. 오늘 시간이 좀 많이
지나서 유통은 우리 박스도 지난주에
했었고 지난주인가요? 지난주에
했었네. 어, 지난주에 했었고 그리고
오늘 잠깐 우리 선부 대리에 코멘트도
있어서 여기까지 보도록 하고 가장
많이 등장하는 이은택 위원님의 이그전
자료 어 보고 넘어가겠습니다.
>> 네. 엔택 연구원님 자료가 있었고요.
역사가 말하는 주도주 솔림 쏠릴 때가
좋을 때다라고 하는데 사실
이인택연구님이 얘기란지가 너무
오래됐고이 내용을 제가 많이 활용을
했거든요.
>> 근데 이전에 썼던 자료랑 뭐 다를게
없기 때문에 뭐 그냥 내용 스킵하고
>> 어 핵심만 말씀을 드리면
>> 결국엔
뭐 금리가 올라가건
뭐 하건 오히려 금리 올라가면
주도주적으로의 솔림 현상이 더 강해질
수밖에 없다. 그게 다컴버 때
그랬다라고 하고요. 금리가 올라가게
되면 아까 부사장님도 말씀해
주셨다시피 실적 가시성이 높은 섹터로
매기가 쏠릴 수밖에 없다라는 거.
>> 국내 시장으로 보면 그게 AI
관련주가 되는 거죠. 뭐 반도체,
변합기 뭐 이런 쪽으로 이제 쏠릴
수밖에 없다라는 이야기를 연구원님이
하는 거고요. 자, 아래 자료를 보면
>> 다컴버블 주도 업종 95년에서
98년까지 세업종이 함께 주도를
했었는데
>> 여기서 이제 뭐 바이오텍이나 그리고
금융주, 그 IT 이렇게였다면 금리가
올리고 나서는 SMP 500이나
이런게 좀 약해지고 나스닥이 굉장히
강했었다라고 하고요. 여기서 또 뭐가
올랐냐라고 결국에 AI 반도체
쪽으로만 쏠렸었다.
아 그때는 이제 인터넷 쪽이죠.
관련주로만 쏠려 갔었다라는 이야기를
했고
오른쪽은 금융업종 12개월 포워드피랑
뭐 증권 업종 피 그리고 헬스케어
업종이라고
하는데 어 결국이 다컴버 때이 부분들
다 탈락했었라고 하더라고요. 쪽
인터넷 쪽으로만 몰려갔었다라고 하는데
그런 부분을 좀 이야기 하고 싶었던
거 같습니다. 그래서 오히려 어
AI 쪽이 아닌 다른 업종으로의
수급도 퍼지면서 다 같이 올라가는
모돌리 상승이 나오면 거기가 이제
꼭지일 가능성도 없다. 그런 얘기까지
있어요.
>> 음.
[웃음]
>> 우리 오장 90년대생인데 모돌이 이런
말 쓰면 안 돼.
>> 아, 정문이 왔어요. [웃음]
>> 감사합니다. 예. 내용이 몇 번
이렇게 최근에 반복해 주셨던 내용과
많이 다르진 않은 거 같아요.
그래서 보도록 하고 마지막에 여기
[콧방귀] 어 1 2 3번 이렇게
크게 굵은 글씨로 써 주신 것들 보면
어 30년 전 투자자와 똑같은 투자
형태를 보이는 현재 투자자
>> 실적이 없어도 다컴이면 상승 지금도
실적이 없어도 AI 로봇을 한다고
하면 급등이 말투가 오장인데
[웃음]
>> 제가 배운 거 배운 거 맞이
>> 그 오과장이 이게 원문을 고대로
올려왔나 의심스러운데 원문 맞아요
>> 아 그 리포트 원문
아, 그대로 그대로.
>> 어, 진짜 말투가 왠지 이렇게 오과장
음성이 패치돼서 들리는 [웃음] 거.
>> 그래서 뭐 최근에 LG CNS 뭐
LG 전자 이런 거 올랐었잖아요.
>> 네.
>> 저는 그때 그런 거 올라가는 거 보고
좀 어, 시장이 좀 무섭다라는 생각이
들었는데 왜냐면 실적으로 바로
연결되는 내용도 아니고
>> 뭐 LG CNS나 삼성 STS 이런
종목이 안 좋은 회사라는게 아니라
>> 네. 메리트가 크지는 않은
회사들이임에도 불구하고 막 상한가를
가는 걸 보고
>> 아 시장이 좀 불안한데라는 생각을
>> 했었거든요. 그래서
>> 친구들도 주식을 많이 하는데
>> 저한테 야 LG CNS 뭐 좋은 거
아니야 막 그래서 막 샀다고
하더라고요. 뭐 지금 다 물려 있는
걸로 알고
>> 그런 거 쉽게 접근하지 말라 막
그랬는데
>> 개인 투자들이 그런 쪽으로 엄청
접근을 많이 하더라고요.
>> [콧방귀]
>> 참 선별해서 투자하는게 중요하고
이제 오매블만 봐야 되는데 아 가야
하는데 요즘 오가장 승률이 어때요?
>> 한 57 정도 되는 걸로 알고
있습니다.
>> 제 기억에 60% 이렇게 붙었다가
조금 밑으로 내려왔다 항상 그랬는데
지금 양화입니다.
>> 네
>> 오늘은 어떻게 됩니까?
>> 아 저부턴가 어 누구부터 했지? 어
미국부터
>> 미국부터
>> 사장님 오늘은 양입니까? 아, 오늘
오늘 상승입니다. 왜냐면
>> FMC 기자 회견 끝나고 아, 약간
사람들이
>> 좀 기대를 한 사람들이 좀 주식을
샀었나 봐요. 그 그냥 네피스인데
>> 네. 어, 별거 없네 하면서
팔았거든요. 근데 그 파는 속도가
약간 그 시간이 지나면 지날수록
매도의 매도를 부르면서
거의 상승법을 거의 다 반납하다시피
해서 어, 83들 다 한 거
같거든요.
>> 그런데 장 끝난 이후에 어, M 뭐
이란간에 MU도 체결이 됐고 애플
관련해서
>> 메모리 구족 때문에 가격을 올려야
되겠다.
>> 음. 이런 부분들이 다시 확인이 되고
있기 때문에 메모리 병목이 다시
확인이 되고 있기 때문에
메모리 중심에
>> 어 상승이 오늘도 미국 시장에서
나타날 수 있다라고 보고 있고
>> 또 아까 유리프로가 얘기했던 대로
계속해서 어 맵을 증해야 되기 때문에
이번에는 반도시 장비주 사이클이
이전보다
좀 강하고 길게 갈 수 있다는
분석들이 좀 나오고 있습니다.
>> 네.
>> 그래서 어 뭐 그게 메모리처럼 뭐 몇
배 간다는 것이 아니라
>> 음
>> 계속해서 어 꾸준히 우상향하는 패턴을
그리지 않을까? 그리고 이제 메모리,
장비 어 이런 부분들이 시 어
지수 시총에서 상위권을 차지하고
있거든요. 그래서 일단은 단기적으로
그 부분들이 필반 지수를 이끌지
않을까라고 생각을 합니다.
>> 알겠습니다.
>> 방승 우리 유리프로는네
>> 저도 SP랑 마스닥 둘 다
상승이고요. MC 관련해서 이미 어느
정도 쇼크 쇼크가 있었다면 좀 소화를
했다라고 생각하고 그리고 19일이 또
휴정입니다. 미국이.
>> 네. 무슨 날이죠?
>> 준틴트 홀리데이라고 해서 그 노예
해방
>> 관련해진데. 그래서 휴장이라서
거래량은 좀 줄어들 수 있는데 그래도
반등할 것이라고 봅니다. 알겠습니다.
미국은 전부 다 상승.
>> 예.
>> 우리 오가장 시간을 몇 분 더
벌었어요. 장을 봤습니까? 볼린저
밴드 상단에 또 붙었습니까?
>> 아, [웃음] 차트는 안 봤는데요.
>> 네.
>> 이미 답을 정해 놓고 들어왔기 때문에
>> 아, 네.
>> 양봉 가능성이 높고요.
>> 음. 그리고 어 어제 보니까
이은택 연구원님 말처럼 금리 올려
버리니 다른 거 다 빠지고 반도체
미국에서 반도체 관련된 종목들
쪽으로만 가더라고요. 마이크론
장비주들 AMD 이런 종목들만 가는
거를 봐서
어 결국에 반도체가 가면 지수는 가는
거니까 양봉 날 가능성이 좀 높다라고
보고요. 그래서 오늘도 안봉해
보겠습니다. 알겠습니다. 코스닥
어떻게 됩니까?
>> 안봉입니다.
>> 응.
>> 눈봉입니다.
>> 눈봉. 어,
>> 이유는
[웃음]
이유가 어디습니까? 이런 말을 하면
안 되지. 우리 어, 분석해서 하는
사람들인데.
>> 아, 네. 뭐 뭐 뭐 [웃음]
즉 결과가 나오니까 음봉 네.
표시했습니다. [목을 가다듬음]
>> 어,
>> 저의 모델에 의하면 저의 시스템에
의하면 음봉입니다. 이렇게 얘기하죠.
이유가 어디습니까? 그러면 [웃음]
당황스럽죠?
>> 예.
>> 알겠습니다. 그러면 혹시
>> 내일도 예측이 가능한가요? 아니면
오늘 장이나 뭐 이런 거 봐야
되나요?
>> 오늘 장 봐야 합니다.
>> 음네. 알겠습니다. 오늘은 어 코스
피는 양봉. 네.
>> 코스 닭은 음봉.
네. 알겠습니다. 오늘 체슬릭 오닝
브리프 9시 좀 넘었는데요. 10부
순서 여기서 마치도록 하고 오늘도
행복하고 즐거운 투자 되시길 바라면서
덥습니다. 건강에도 이해하시고 질문이
있으시면 남겨 주시면 아마 점립도
보시니까 워신박에서 어 답변도 주실
것 같습니다. 오늘 2부까지 긴 시간
함께 해 주신 최밀탄 여러분들께
감사드리면서 마치도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다. 감사합니다.
아